good morning everybody and welcome to uh
environment and agriculture welcome back
happy New Year glad to see you all
here I would like to first begin with
the Pledge of Allegiance and uh
representative come would you please
lead
us I pledge allegiance to the flag of
the United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
justice for
all thank
you first off I would like to um welcome
a new member to our committee
representative Paige
bimman good to see you and thank you for
joining
us and I would also like to
um give the floor to um representative
Bixby or oh oh Murray representative
Murray for a few
words thank you madam chair um this
morning I'd like to read a brief
statement on behalf of the the members
here in environment and agriculture we'd
like to take a moment to acknowledge the
passing of a former member of
environment and agriculture The
Honorable Suzanne Smith who served in
Ena from 2009 to
2012 before moving to resources
Recreation and development where from
2013 to 2014 she served as Vice chair
and chaired from 2019 to 2020 she served
in the New Hampshire house from 2008 to
2022 Suzanne worked tirelessly to form
bipartisan consensus in all that she did
most
recently uh she came before the
environment and agriculture committee to
teach us and the public about
establishing a fund to treat cyano
bacteria in New Hampshire Lakes it
passed as a result the funds and an
advisory committee were signed into law
and that effort will continue on house
environment and agriculture is grateful
for her service and dedication to New
Hampshire and making the environment
better for us
all with that I'd like to have a moment
of silence in her memory can I yes
representative Bigby so um when Suzanne
was uh already a leader when I came when
I first came in 2012 13 uh and uh I
really looked up to her as a mentor
through the whole time that she was here
in the house um she was really good at
uh getting beyond the partisan divide
and uh de and getting people to work
towards practical Solutions and that
that um that drive towards finding a
practical solution uh was something that
I really admired in her and I try to
follow that
example representative kraton yeah thank
you madam chair
uh yeah that sort of hits hard I'm sorry
I didn't know that um Suzanne Smith uh
obvious was the was the Democratic head
of the rr&d during the last term um but
I learned a ton from her on how to get
things done in a committee and uh if you
just look at the way she conducted
herself and and that the way that she
was able to uh as representative Bixby
said cut through sort of political um
divides and come to reasonable Solutions
she was she was a master at that and I'm
really sorry hear that uh really
tremendous
lady thank you and I'd just like to have
a moment of silence uh in her
memory thank
you
our first bill to be heard this morning
is hb1
1293 and I would like to open up that
hearing and welcome representative ball
to introduce this bill to our committee
good
morning
good morning my name is Lori ball and I
am a representative from Salem thank you
for allowing me to present this very
important bill that addresses one facet
in our fight against CYO bacteria that
is plaguing New Hampshire lakes and
ponds for the past several
years according to the New Hampshire
shoreline water quality protection act
five it is illegal to apply fertilizers
within 25 ft of the reference or high
water line on any new hampsh public
water bodies however no restrictions are
in place for properties that do not abut
public water bodies or storm drains that
carry contaminated water into many lakes
and ponds in fact according to the 2016
New Hampshire guide to storm water
management excess storm water runoff
becomes a problem as the runoff can
carry pollution into lakes ponds and
streams and Coastal Waters making them
unsafe for swimming and creating an
unsafe habitat for fish and other
animals in fact storm waterer runoff
contributes to 90% of the water quality
problems in New
Hampshire roofs driveways and other hard
Services create storm water runoff the
way we manage and care for our property
and the runoff it creates can have a
huge impact on the entire
Watershed given that there is no
fertilizer
restrictions uh setrack restrictions
from St storm brains storm drains runoff
from the entire waterers shev may
contain fertilizer that can contribute
to excess nutrients that build up plant
and algae growth including cob bacteria
which can harm humans and animals and be
a nuisance for swimming and boating
these nutrients can decrease the amount
of oxygen in the water as plants die and
decompose this means
many this means less oxygen is available
for fish and other organisms they can
also increase bacteria that can make
swimmers sick and lead to beach
closers bacteria is not does not only
pose a public health risk it can also
cause an economic hardship for
communities that rely on bathing beaches
for tourism
Revenue the recent New Hampshire
Department of Environmental Services
Statewide cob bacteria action plan made
it clear that Statewide and local
efforts to control nutrient inputs are
critical to curve the potential for
Caceria blooms to occur in fact to
achieve the goals of that plan the
report stated and I quote the primary
focus should be on the reduction of
nutrient loads in particular phosphorus
to the state's water
surfaces the control of phosphorus loads
will limit the nutrient that drive Soo
bacteria production in the States lakes
ponds rivers and
streams house bill 1293 reflects
phosphorous fertilizer restrictions and
public education measures taken by over
11 other States including Maine Vermont
and Massachusetts these measures are
designed to curtail phosphorus overload
in Lakes Pond streams and rivers the
cost of implementing these measures
would be minimal and clearly doable as
given other states have already enacted
them
in addition to my research into the
other states I presented this bill in
draft format to the New Hampshire
enironment Department of Environmental
Services Water Division assistant
director the Salem Municipal service
director and the Salem director of
engineering as well as speaking with the
commissioner of the New Hampshire
Department of Environmental Services who
direct me to another member of his team
to speak about it further I would like
to thank each of these gentlemen for
their input into the development of
House Bill
1293 while cob bacteria may cause may
have many causes including water
temperature and weather storm water
runoff containing fertilizer is a cause
the New Hampshire Department of
Environmental Services CYO bacteria
action plan has acknowledged as an area
that needs our primary focus please vote
OTP on House Bill 1293 so we can take
positive steps to assure New Hampshire
lakes and ponds continue to be the recre
rec recreational focal point of our
beautiful state thank
you thank you representative
ball um can you please
um be uh be able to give uh electronic
uh written testimony to our clerk for
what you were you already have that yes
I brought in um but I can send it in
electronically if that's easier oh well
whatever paper yeah the paper copine I
found a couple typos so I'll have to
correct those first sorry no worries
thank you any questions from the
committee um representative sofikitis
Mike please Mike please put your mic on
please how widespread are the is the use
of phosphorus how how much of the
um supply of fertilizers have phosphorus
in them
currently phosphorus INF fertilizer in
New Hampshire is technically illegal um
we're only allowed to have 67% of
phosphorus in the fertilizer and the way
the fertilizer companies when they
package it they only report in whole
numbers so that middle number when they
put the um nitrogen phosphorus and I
think pottassium that number is always
zero so on a average you know if you
just wanted to put fertilizer on your
lawn um it would say zero on those
phosphorus bags however if you are doing
new um a new lawn or
um some other some other things that we
specified in the bill then you could use
phosphorus that has
fertilizer the concern is more that we
have setbacks when we live on the lakeef
fronts we have setbacks of the 25 ft
that we can't put any any fertilizer
close to the lake because of the runoff
but in in the case of in particular in
Salem on Arlington p Pond our Watershed
goes out could be a mile but all of
those other homes that don't have
setbacks from the waters and the streams
or the storm drains all that water ends
up going in and in in Arlington it dumps
directly into Arlington Pond there is no
holding place for it everything dumps
directly into the pond um and as a
result our pond was shut I think all of
but three weeks this summer we shut down
in may we opened up mid June we shut
down again I think it was on July 28th
and we did not reopen until November 8th
or 10th as a matter of fact we opened
just before they start pulling the water
from our pond to become to go to the
water treatment because we are the
secondary
Reservoir representative Bixby yes um
thank you for taking my question and uh
thank you for bringing this bill in uh I
think it's very important I just wanted
to get a clarification on a couple of
things um uh one is um the when you when
you B say no fertilizer can be applied
uh you're talking about uh turf
fertilizer right yes and that was the
one thing in the bill that we need to
specify that it's um phosphorus
fertilizers with
phosphorus follow up follow up go ahead
yeah so there are a number of a number
of agricultural fertilizers which have a
lot more phosphorus than uh than Turf
fertilizers those are are not intended
for application on uh on on Turf
obviously um but uh the in SE on page
two section six of the bill um
application of fertilizers containing
phosphorus is prohibited during Heavy
Rain or when Heavy Rain is predicted or
on saturated ground or from October 15
to April 1st including applications by
professionals so uh am I correct in
reading that that that that is that is
any fertilizer that contains phosphorus
not merely Turf fertilizers that are um
prohibited during that
period I am was thinking in terms of
phosphorus um fertilizer when writing
this and um
the side farms and those agricultural
things for gardening agricultural golf
courses they're all exempt from this
okay um okay so I
guess
uh I I I was what I'm what I'm not sure
of is whether the
exemption uh is covers the
application uh during that prohibition
period or whether that whether the
exemption is during the normal season
when one would be
applying that I went by the other laws
and how they were written written with
the idea that we would not be applying
any fertilizer to frozen ground because
it would just run off right so I guess
my the point of my question is uh do we
not do we want to prevent application of
any fertilizer including agricultural
fertilizers that contain phosphorus
during those
periods to be totally transparent I I
was advised not to include these areas
because the possibility of passing the
bill would be much smaller if we
included saying that for agricultural
reasons you can't apply I maybe I'm Mis
I'm still misunderstanding you or okay
okay I I um
I I I think that the
um I think the the key of my question is
that um um there seems to be a an
ambiguity between whether the exemption
is uh for uh for phosphorus fertilizer
is um uh carries over to section six
where it says that um applications are
prohibited during Heavy Rain Etc uh
and uh and I would my my personal
feeling is that it probably makes sense
to limit any application of phosphorus
during that period because you can run
run off Farmland as well as you can run
off um or run off a golf course as well
as you can run off uh ordinary Turf uh
so uh I just want to have a
clarification about whether the intent
was to limit the application of all
phosphorus for those times when it can
be appropriately absorbed by the the
plants the intent was that it should not
be applied when the ground is frozen and
it cannot get into the ground any
fertilizer should not be
um this particularly says application of
fertilizers containing phosphorus are
prohibited during heavy rains okay thank
you I'm sorry if I'm still not
understanding your question no I I think
I think you you've answered that is is
that when it comes to not applying
during those conditions it doesn't
matter whether it's a labeled as turf
fertilizer or or whether it's um you
know yes whether it you anything that
has phosphorus shouldn't be applied when
it's going to inevitably run off yes
that would be exactly what I'm talking
about because whether it comes from a
golf course or agriculture it's going to
end up in our stream so we want them to
apply it during the proper times right
thank you representative Katon yeah I'm
sorry just to make sure I heard what you
said so there are no exemptions for six
so those
those uh seven exceptions in in
five they they're not accepted in six
they've got to comply with six they
cannot those people golf courses cannot
apply fertilizer when the ground is
Frozen yes okay um I have a a question
on um paragraph
uh on paragraph seven and we last term
we looked at uh rodeno sites and one of
the issues was the how do you prevent
going on Amazon and ordering Foss
for fertili fertilizers how how how does
seven get implemented is that is there
any accountability to that
or considering I in my mind I was
thinking how California has so many uh
restrictions and it's just not allowed
to be um sent into their so however they
would do it it would be the same we just
it would not be allowed okay so there
would be a restriction put in place and
I'm not exactly sure on the mechanisms I
assume there were mechanisms already in
place for restrictions yeah okay thank
you representative
Duty
uh
yeah somebody has to shut that
yeah now you're on I was on all the time
oh I didn't know that look at that okay
um this goes back to section four uh
basically lines four five and six and I
just didn't understand so it says
display nonphosphorus fertilizer
separately from phosphorus in the retail
area where phosphorus fertilizer is
accessible by a consumer and I didn't
understand why that was necessary or
what the object objective of that was
the intent of that is to um better
educate the consumer to make sure that
they don't mix up the two fertilizers
and pick up one rather than the other so
the idea is just a separate area would
mean a separate shelf or a separate um
necessarily a location but just to
separate them so they're not next to
each other there's also um the posting
of the sign um to allow again this goes
back to one of the things that was
mentioned in the um Department of
environment Services action plan was
that we needed more ways of educating
the public in New Hampshire the majority
of properties do not even need
phosphorus in fact if you just left your
grass clippings there you would have
enough phosphorus on your lawn you don't
need to add anything so we're really
trying to educate the public and the
purpose for separating those whether
they're on different shelves or on one
side of the aisle and then the other
side is just to make sure that we're
educating um and letting the the public
know that there are two distinct reasons
for buying the fertilizer and if you're
not EST establishing a new lawn then
that's not the fer then you should not
be buying that
fertilizer uh represent uh
Murray thank you madam chair um and
thank you for taking my question so I
think going back to the comment that um
the vice chair um uh representative
kraton had brought up regarding the
online sales um is that something that
you would be open to enumerating who
would have oversight there in the event
that because right now it's not very
clear as to who would be
um caring for the oversight of the
online sale portion and and to
representative craton's point we did
hear in a previous piece of legislation
around oversight and some of the
complexities around that so I'm just
curious if that I'm more than willing to
amend this in order to um better Serve
the People and to address the io
bacteria problems I can certainly talk
to legislative Services the researchers
to find out if there is something that
we can add to
this okay representative
ger thank you madam chair and thank you
representative Paul for uh taking my
question uh to return to uh page two
section six that uh representative Bixby
was referring to uh previously uh this
prohibition during Heavy Rain or or when
Heavy Rain is predicted uh and then so
this presumably covers both private
individuals and and including uh
applications by professionals and so I'm
wondering what kind of enforcement
mechanism are we are we talking about
because we're talking about
professionals who are applying
fertilizers there are ways to to
restrict or to
regulate how professionals do these
things right because they have to be
licensed or there are various ways of
doing that but um how would we you know
what enforcement mechanism is there when
we're talking about private individuals
who are also that applies then below
with putting it you know you shouldn't
be putting it on a hard surface where
it's going to run off but my question is
what enforcement mechanisms are there
when we're talking about private
individuals it would be the same
enforcement mechanisms that are in place
right now saying that we have to have a
setback from the water which I'm going
to tell you is not enforcable so the
only thing that this bill really does is
going to rely on people's honesty and
being educated through the bill and the
um commercial people that are putting
this down I would imagine if complaints
came in and said hey they just put
fertilizer on my property and it's
pouring rain and and complaints go in we
would be looking a lot closer at their
lure so I think it's the same thing I
know that I have a lawn company that
does fertilizer on my property and I
know that when it's raining they
cancel thank you very
much anyone is oh represent
Dan thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question I wonder if the Farm
Bureau has weighed in on this at all if
you've gotten any input from them I have
not okay thank
you and I have not received any written
testimony from them as well
representative Bixby uh additionally I
was wondering if you have consulted the
Department of Agriculture because
they're actually the ones who are in
charge of enforcing fertilizer
regulations I did not I was um the
guidance I was given was to talk to the
Department of Environmental Services
thank you and the person I spoke to was
the person who wrote the original bill
that um that restricted phosphorus um in
the fertilizers okay great thank
you representative
Penza thank you for taking my question I
know you're not a scientist but I would
just could you speak to a little bit
about um the chemical reaction that
takes place with the phosphorus that
increases the cob bacteria I grew up on
a lake ever since you know I was was uh
born we had a summer home and it's a
huge problem um you know it was one of
the cleanest Lakes but not anymore in
New Hampshire um you know and it's
interesting
because there I never knew anything
about this at all um until I met this
gentleman that had that did Lawns and he
told me about that and the natural piece
of this so could you speak to like what
transpires that causes
this as you said
I acknowledge I am not a scientist
however in my reading the phosphorus
helps to develop the root systems is
what I was told and so that's you know
that's what we want to put on our plants
to make them healthy and strong and have
good root systems um and that's what
happens when it gets into the water that
the bacteria that's in there the plants
in there including invasive plants are
going to overtake um the water and once
you it's going to just end up depleting
the oxygen it just becomes a cycle of
killing the lake off
slowly thank
you sure representative
Bixby I do not see anybody from any of
our agencies uh listed as someone who is
going to
talk um representative
ktoa
thank you madam chair um a couple
questions uh if I may um the date here
in section six
um October 15 through April
1st um is that a date that's already in
law somewhere
else all of the um information that I
put in was already part of um what other
states did when I looked in especially
into Maine when I I pulled their laws so
everything that is written here is a
combination of what the other states
around us are doing including Vermont
Massachusetts and Maine follow up follow
up go ahead so it's not in New Hampshire
law not as far as I know follow
up go ahead thank you and thank you
again for taking my question so I
understand that October 15th uh
technically the ground is crowen uh the
ground is frozen but lately with the way
the climate has been um we're still able
to work the fields in October and I
think um putting in a date um based on
how things are going might be a uh
harm uh folks because people in in
agriculture um if they're needing to
apply a fertilizer at that
time
I don't think it's saying that it can't
be applied it's saying it can't be
applied if it's saturated or Frozen no
or from October 15 through April
1st
okay we can certainly I can certainly
amend that to say um between that time
period again I went by um Vermont and in
Vermont uh it's prohibited from October
16th to March 31st on Frozen Ground so
maybe we just I can amend it to
clarify followup go ahead thank you
madam chair um now what concerned me a
little bit in your testimony well in in
answering the questions is this is being
targeted
um to homeowners basically to the
private
citizen however um you kind of alluded
that it could be more you it was um you
inferred that you had to water it down
um and exclude um agricultural use and
gardening uh so that this bill get
passed my question to you is
agriculture uh and gardening rely
heavily on phosphorus uh NPK uh the
three that you were talking about
specifically uh in order to make sure
that they uh can grow their crops
and uh feed the populace of New
Hampshire and what I'm concerned about
with this bill
is at some future point we may end up
going down the road of banning it for
those purposes um based on what you
stated do you see that
happening I mean there's a possibility
that that could happen I believe that
the intent of not including agricultural
use or golf courses for management um is
because we're dealing with people who
are running their business and who um
follow the laws and they know how to
apply these uh chemicals in an
appropriate manner it is the general
public that I'm concerned about who do
not apply it in appropriate Manner and
are not educated on the impact of when
they put fertilizer and it over spills
onto their driveway and they just push
it down the storm drain that they're not
understanding where the storm drain
actually goes to and where it disperses
its water so my hope would be that if um
golf course and agriculture are using
these that they are very well educated
in how to appropriate appropriately
apply uh chemicals um so that it does
not hurt the
environment representative ktoa you had
another question and then representative
NAB just just a follow basic followup in
thank you again oh uh sorry about that
uh just a basic followup to to your
answer is so basically what you're
saying and what I'm hearing here is this
is an education Bill we need to educate
the consumer and you're using this as a
way to educate people well that's only
one facet is to educate them but we
still need to put the restrictions okay
thank you representative NAB thank you
madam chair um I would think that part
six is something that is um self-evident
that you would not apply fertilizer if
the was frozen and not going to take it
in or if it was going to run off and be
useless and that commercial applicators
would in particular understand that but
I think it would be helpful to get some
input from the Farm Bureau and or the
Department of Agriculture um just to
make sure the fact that they haven't
emailed about this bill makes me think
that it's not a concern but I think it
would be helpful to have their input on
that because it will have an impact on
Farmers absolutely than you
representative Bixby yeah
another uh sort of um
and be good unclear area is um whether
uh the you uh whether the use of uh
phosphorus in a greenhouse would count
as an
application and uh I think that the the
bill should directly address have
something specific to indicate uh how
this how phosphorus should be managed in
green houses and if this if this
prohibition affects that because uh
during you know
unlike the uh the outside applications
which people aren't applying phosphorus
right now uh it's uh
but uh but um at least outside but
people are using phosphorus and Green
Houses because it's an important
nutrient for Greenhouse plants uh it's
it's a controlled environment but we
might want to have something in here
that addresses the fact that Greenhouse
applications are not uh affected by this
bill would you
agree well it says gardening but I could
certainly add in um Greenhouse gardening
right but I think so the it's the EXE
the exemptions that are listed in five
don't uh cover six the way that the bill
is written uh where so uh there for six
would need to have a specific exemption
uh indicating that green houses don't
have that seasonal restriction
oh I see what you're saying yes okay
thank you and uh I I also have a concern
um in in the list of um
exemptions that we don't include um
municipalities who may need to apply
fertilizer to Parks uh Recreation
areas well they can if the soil is
tested and they see that it's phosphorus
Des um
deficit otherwise there would be no
reason to be applying it okay but I
mean you've outlined a few of the other
exemptions specifically for gardening
agricultural use I would think U
municipal use would also be something
that would be Exempted again this is
going to even on these ex exemptions um
for agricultural use and for the
um I I just think if you're talking
about parks that before before they
would be applying anything they would be
checking to see what exactly is needed
and that would be that they would do a
soil sample to see that there's a
phosphorous def deficit and then they
would go ahead and put that um use those
fertilizers so why wouldn't the same
logic be applied to golf
courses it certainly could
be okay thank you we can certainly add
that and amend
it any other questions from the
committee representative
smart I have to think how to formulate
it as a question thank you madam chair
um you have down exemptions first of all
I think um you said in the beginning
that New Hampshire the state of New
Hampshire prohibits phosphorus in its
fertilizers up to0
67% or after that and there's and
there's no way to enforce it so what's
the point of the bill if we can't
enforce it and there's already a rule
that you can't have phosphorus in your
fertilizer because even even phosphorus
with 67 or even fertilizer with 67% is
still going to even that at that minimal
amount if it goes into our storm drains
and ends up in our Watershed which ends
up in our Lakes is going to cause harm
which is why when you abut a lake you
can't put Point s you can't put any
fertilizer within 25 ft regardless so um
it's my understanding that
agriculture um like my husband does
haying he has 100 foot setback so why is
it 25 ft for a homeowner but 100 set
foot setb for Farms the 25 foot is
already set in law I don't know the
answer for
that don't you think it's a little bit
like it should be the same for everybody
I was going to increase it to 50 feet
and then I said I in my head I was just
like if the law already says 25 ft I
would leave it to what the current law
states and there's no mention I'm sorry
can I another there's no mention of um
Road uh Highway departments a lot of
times with the ditching with the highway
departments I mean your house is a mile
away but you're up on a hill and that
water runs down over the hill over the
road and down into the lake say Alton
area um
there's no I don't see any provision in
here that educates the highway
department on how to maintain the roads
to keep the runoff from going into the
Lakes number one and number two I think
homeowners my personal feeling
on um runoff from your home if you own
property around the lake that there
should be some sort of a filtration
system put in to keep the a natural
filtration system not one that you know
um to keep
this fil filter the water before it gets
into the lake so it's a a landowner's
problem well that's the whole purpose of
that the people who live on the lake are
doing the correct thing we are we have
ways of mitigating or putting um you
know like at my house in particular the
water when it runs across my yard then
goes into a bunch of stone before it
would enter the lake so it has time to
dissipate into the soil um with regard
to the highway I would think that um
I I won't say I find it hard to believe
but I'd be very disappointed if the
highway system when they create those
ditches are not creating it to catch the
water and have the water then filtrate
through the ground and not run directly
into the lake as I said our concern at
least in the Salem area is that our
storm drains regardless if you're in the
Watershed which is huge um it doesn't
matter where you where you live if
you're not using the precautions that we
on the Laker are being that we have to
use and the setbacks all that same water
is just going to run into the storm
drains and go directly in I mean I wish
that there was a a law in place that
actually said all Waters in a storm
drain have to go into a holding so that
it then has to dissipate and filter
through the ground instead of running
directly but that apparently is not in
place in New Hampshire because I know we
have about 20 uh storm drain Outlets
coming directly into our
Lake okay um did I I'm sorry did I not
answer the question no you answered that
fine I'm just wondering why not make
storm drain catch Basin a law versus
this because we don't have storm rain
catch Basin right now and I would think
that would be a he a lot more expensive
and to push onto towns where they don't
have the property I think that they have
no areas to put those catch Basin I
think a lot of times when we write laws
um that have to do with Lakes We tend to
think of the North country and people
who have acreage around Arlington Pond
we have our lots are 50 feet by 100 feet
so we don't have a lot of space down
there and we don't have any public um
access access to the beaches or to the
lake um and so some of the things that
we're you know that we apply for the
lakes in the North Region of our state
where they have a lot of property um and
you come down to the southern region
where we have a much more congested
environment we don't have the areas to
put in these catch basins or um you know
the same it it can't be kind of I guess
a one-size fits all and again I go back
to the um
to the report that was just written and
it specifically said that we need to
address the phosphorus coming into um
the
waters I don't know if everybody had I
would I sorry I just assumed everyone
had already seen that report it just
came out in November representative
Duty uh yes thank you madam chair um I
just want to if this bill b gets passed
and it only educates people about
phosphorous on their lawns I think it's
done a a service also it will open up
the opportunity for homeowners to have
more options and getting zero phosphorus
fertilizer um but uh as a member of the
nashwa Conservation Commission one of
the things that I have seen is that
people need to be educated
that Lawns um serve absolutely no
purpose in the environment other than to
make people feel good when they look out
their window or to give people something
to do on the weekends when they get on
their riding
lawnmower uh so we have been trying to
encourage people to limit the size of
their lawns uh and to populate it with
um plants that uh are native to New
Hampshire and that will provide
substance and food for our Wildlife so I
just want to say that I appreciate this
bill um you know it looks like it needs
a little bit of work but it doesn't
appear to me to be anything that will
kill it and I'm hoping that our
committee will do its due diligence on
it thank you very much thank
you okay if we have no other questions
from the committee we can move on we've
got five other people who would like to
speak and they have indicated did two to
three minutes each which would be good
so uh I would like to call Joanne
sigua
[Music]
to our testimony table good
morning and I see you are from Dees I'm
from
the microphone
please I'm I'm from I'm a representative
of the Kizer Lake protective Association
which is in Sutton New Hampshire um
that's a a small Lake it's um
approximately 182 Acres average depth of
9 ft but when we say 9 ft there's areas
that are 27 feet there's areas that are
2 feet or less so it's a very small Lake
and um um I want to talk a little bit
one of your uh Representatives mentioned
about the science um when you have a a
small Lake uh it's very shallow you know
in certain areas and the sunlight hits
the bottom of the lake which encourages
plant growth so there's actually a
difference between ponds and lakes ponds
usually are called ponds because
technically they the sunlight hits the
bottom of the lake all the time before
you go on are you affiliated with
Department of Environmental services at
all no I'm not okay thank you okay so
but basically um um the phosphorus
encourages photosynthesis that's the
whole thing okay so the phosphorus and
nitrogen and all that collects in there
it encourages photosynthesis
photosynthesis the light right the
plants absorb the light and grow and of
course um they can grow to excess
depending on how much ph phosphorus or
nitrogen they have so if there if if
there's tons of phosphorus in in lakes
and ponds plant growth is going to
exponentially grow and what happens is
photosynthesis actually removes the
carbon and but produces the oxygen um
and what um what happens is um when the
plants uh which is great for fish that's
why there's some plants in there it's
great for fish and it's it's gung-ho but
what happens is if there's overgrowth it
actually um it it covers the top of the
lake so like algae you know sign of
bacteria all those um um plants they it
covers the top of the lake what happens
is if it covers the top of the lake um
it reduces the surface area of the lake
so it the lake can't absorb oxygen so
when the lake can't absorb oxygen all
the other fish and all the other
creatures that are in that Lake die
because now there's no Oxygen so that's
why it's so important to decrease the
phosphorous from all the lakes and the
ponds and um and one of um one of one of
the things that um you uh you mentioned
that um the education is really really
important because people don't
understand that and in New Hampshire I
you know I actually live on Kar Lake um
we've had an influx of new population
they don't understand um the laws or the
or understand the lake period um and
there's been a lot more construction so
if there's more construction there's
been more you know growing of grass and
and and using uh fertilizers so we're
seeing um uh we ker lake has been
monitored very um seriously because in
the 70s it was one of the lakes that was
heavily polluted Ed and actually came
back it's a success story and it came
back and it's wonderful now but we have
noticed in this particular Lake um an
increase in C
cyanobacteria and we we believe it's
possibly um you know the phosphorus and
also uh we have a beach on our small
Lake and so an influx of more people on
the beach as well so the phosphorus and
nitrogen all that is is is increasing
that uh that uh food that Source I
wouldn't say food but the source that
the plants needs these minerals to to um
have photosynthesis and because of the
fact that it is so shallow it it it can
be a problem and we just want to protect
it but it's not just for ker Lake uh you
know it we know that like for instance
her Pond and things and other lakes in
New Hampshire are experiencing all the
same thing and so um so we do support
this bill ke Lake Protection Association
does support this bill and um I don't
want to take take too much long of the
process I'm I'm already at 3 minutes so
fing myself but we I we do encourage you
guys to really think this over and to
pass uh this HB One n uh 1293 thank you
thank you any
questions okay um thank you for your
testimony um we call Andrea Laro from
New Hampshire Lakes good morning and
welcome to environment and
Agriculture and you said three minutes
as well good morning uh thank you uh
Madam chair and committee I am Andrea
Laro the president of New Hampshire
Lakes uh I have a testimony letter
coming around New Hampshire Lakes we're
a Statewide nonprofit organization our
mission is to restore and preserve the
health of our Lakes we represent about
275 local Lake Associations and
thousands of uh res uh Lake enthusiasts
throughout the state um there's been
great discussion um and I think you you
all understand um or have heard about
the connection of phosphorus and
cyanobacteria and water quality I would
like to also let you know I served on
the advisory committee that advised the
Department of Environmental Services in
developing the plan to address
cyanobacteria the toxic blooms that are
increasing in our Lakes increasing in
severity and frequency that report was
published in November
2023 this spill is Con consistent with
that um the action plan of that um
recommendations of that plan and in the
interest of time I just wanted to focus
in on uh kind of one aspect here uh last
week I testified in front of the State
uh the Senate finance committee they're
considering a $1 million appropriation
to the cyano bacteria mitigation loan
and Grant fund which is set up to
provide loans and grants to local Lake
Associations municipalities and water
suppliers to implement uh projects to
reduce uh the contributors to uh toxic
cyanobacteria blooms in our lakes and uh
the Senate finance committee um did
their due diligence and asked me a
number of questions and one of the
questions one they expressed some um
reservation about investing in the fund
you know and I'm paraphrasing here um
putting a Band-Aid on the problem
instead of really addressing the sources
and they asked me what is the state what
are you doing about
fertilizer and so um of course I let
them know about this bill and uh we do
believe that this bill would get at uh
sort of the lwh hanging fruit of
phosphorous contri um pollution to our
Lakes um and New Hampshire Lakes we run
an education program Statewide it's
called uh lak smart we work with
residents to implement lak friendly
things they can do on their property to
um help uh reduce their negative impact
on the lake we have come in contact with
thousands of homeowners over the past
four or five years so that program and I
will tell you um very low understanding
of how to properly apply fertilizer and
the negative impacts fertilizer can
cause and you know a prevailing thought
that you know more is better when it
comes to fertilizer and um so I think
that through the Lakes smart program we
have come into contact with thousands
you know a couple thousand homeowners
throughout the state but there are
thousands and thousands of
homeowners throughout the state that my
small team can't possibly um you know
connect one-on-one with to talk about
the problems of fertilizer so I do think
that um if we can put in a law that
provides more educational opportunities
for these homeowners who do want to do
the right thing and protect their
investment coupled with Ed increased
education and expanding the program that
New Hampshire Lakes is doing I think
it's a win-win and um that's what I have
to say I appre I vote urge you to vote
out to pass um on this bill and I would
be happy to answer any questions thank
you any questions representative Murray
um thank you madam chair and thank you
for taking my question would it be safe
to say that this bill is one of a
two-pronged approach so to speak in
addressing the compound effects of uh
phosphorus runoff it sounds like from
the original Bill's uh sponsor testimony
that there's a compounding effect when
it comes from other locations and then
it kind of trickles down into the lake
but then also um the other sort of arm
that you're speaking about would be
funding as individual remediation
efforts per Lake are quite expensive yes
okay okay so this is sort of one of one
of those one of the two-prong approach
so to speak yes I thank you for the
question yes thank
you any other
questions thank you very much for your
testimony this morning thank you and I
would Now call Joanie I believe McIntyre
is that correct good morning from New
Hampshire Association of realtor in
three minutes good morning and thank you
for the opportunity to speak um as you
just said my name is Joanie miny I'm an
associate broker at coldw Banker J hampy
Associates and I'm this year's president
of the New Hampshire Association of
Realtors um the Realtors would ask that
you support
HB um 1293 the Realtors recognize New
Hampshire's lakes and rivers also
protect and enhance real estate values
for both residential and commercial use
properties on clean well-managed lakes
and rivers are more attractive to buyers
and Property Owners by protecting views
recreational opportunities and overall
quality of life the Realtors
participated in the house house bill
1066 legislative commission which which
reviewed the causes of CYO bacteria
blooms and suggested solutions to remedy
these issues the resulting report which
has been discussed already found that
our water bodies are highly susceptible
to excessive nutrient loads from storm
water runoff hb1 1293 is a respons and
practicable approach to fix the problem
in the most effective way by cutting the
nutrient load in storm water runoff
Realtors as you probably know are highly
protective of property rights and tend
to resist overly combersome or expensive
mandates We Believe HB 1293 is a fair
costeffective approach which will result
in meaningful decrease in nutrient
loading in our water bodies at a minimal
cost to Property Owners real there's
hope that you will um will vote a to
pass on HB
1293 thank you thank you very much any
questions from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much
for sorry representative ktoa thank you
madam chair and I do apologize but could
I get a copy of your testimony please
sure or could I get that testimony thank
you sure should we send it should we
email you can you can send it or you can
just pass it on to representative Davis
thank you thank
you and uh next up is Carl
joerger good morning and you indicated
three minutes to speak sounds
good good morning uh just wanted to say
I do support this bill uh I live on
Arlington Pond also and the pond for the
most part this summer was useless uh it
looked looked great we could put around
the pond but we couldn't actually go in
the water because of the Cal
bacteria uh and back in 20122 we did
have a bloom also then so it it it's not
just this year it's other years that
that the problem is occurring so
phosphorus and uh fertilizer it it's
definitely a problem if you do any
research on it so I do agree uh the one
comment if possible um I would like to
see golf courses also included in the
bill as to restricting the use of a
phosphorus Center fertilizer I
understand agriculture but a golf course
can be a little less green and that's
fine with me because golf courses are
beautifully green and they put a lot of
fertilizer down and they can definitely
run into the Lakes
too okay thank you appreciate your
testimony this
morning
okay um I would like to now uh invite
Aon joerger up to
speak thank you madam chair for letting
me speak good morning good morning I
also live on Arlington Pond and has
already been stated we had very little
recreational time on the lake this
summer um and I'll disagree with my
husband it wasn't pretty because for a
large part of that we had very ugly neon
green in front of our entire property so
it's it affected our quality of life um
it also potentially if this continues
and um escalates as it has been in the
last few years it seems to be getting
worse and worse um for over the past few
years it's going to affect our property
values uh we would have dead fish on our
property so it's affecting the the fish
in the lake as well as people's use of
the lake and I do think that trying to
control the phosphorus is one of several
ways that we can work on that I am part
of a watershed committee that was formed
on the lake um we're going to look at an
entire Watershed plan but we're trying
to educate um work through our
association and educate the residents on
everything that they can do to try to
control what feeds the cyano bacteria
and the phosphorus and INF fertilizer is
definitely a major contributor to that
so thank you very much thank you for
your comments any questions for Miss
jger represent
Penza thank you for taking my question
I'm not sure if someone answered this
already do you approximately know how
many people um live like like on you
know on the lake that have property and
then the second question is is there any
um kind of Public Access as well to the
to the pond there isn't really public a
access there are some people that use um
some Road access Kids jump jump in and
swim from there they put their kayaks in
and fish but there are Lori might know
how many houses on the
RO
Arlington Pond has at least 300 homes
that about it um but I want to preface
and I realize this as I'm listening to
everyone this is not an issue of small
ponds the broads was shut down so I mean
we're talking parts of Lake wiip pasak
were shut down this summer as well um
this all started years ago um I believe
it was representative rang who is really
and she's one of the co-sponsors on this
she really brought this to the for the
Forefront when her Lake had uh Sino
bacteria and they only found that out
because two dogs died and someone took
the dogs and had autopsies done and came
to find out that it was the Cino
bacteria that killed them now what they
did was they kept thinking oh it's from
the manure from the agriculture or from
the farm of the street and once they did
their Lake management plan they found
out it was actually from one of the
holding bins one of the basins that we
were talking about that breached um so
had nothing to do with the manure from
the Farms where everybody we right away
like to try and think of it must be this
and it must be that there are so many
things that cause cob bacteria um blooms
but phosphorus clearly as I said in that
report that was dated just recently in
November of um of 23 um the conclusion
was that one of the prim primary focuses
should be on the phosphorus um overloads
in the lake and how it's getting
there thank
you question if I could just add one one
thing sure go ahead to your question in
addition to the actual houses on the
lake there are Lake Associations and
there are many many houses on the
streets just off of the lake and they do
have um they have boating access and
beach access there are several
associations
beaches that people use as
well okay thank you very much thank you
anything else regarding this bill I
wouldd like the blue sheet please uh
representative Davis 2011 or zero
opposed oh uh so from the online portal
we had 201 people in favor of this bill
and zero opposed to this bill oh one one
neutral one neutral thank you so you
have
that and we have four people on our blue
shet who are in favor of this
bill
so um so I think um we would probably
like to get um some input from
Department of Agriculture on this bill
as well as um Farm
Bureau and other than that um I'm going
to close out this
hearing and give us a few minutes for
the clerk to get set up for the next
hearing which will be for a house bill
1294 so hang on one
second
let me know when you're all
set
okay this is for
1293 I'm okay I am with that I am going
to open up the hearing for HB
1294 uh this is relative to prohibiting
the state of New Hampshire from
enforcing the regulations of the
Environmental Protection
Agency and here to IND introduce the
bill I believe is representative
Granger uh thank you madam chair and uh
members of the committee uh so my name
is representative Granger and uh you
might be thinking that this is a crazy
bill um
and so you might be wondering why I'd
push a bill that uh nullifies the
entirety of the EPA or at least tries to
um the reason is actually pretty simple
we don't exactly know what part of the
EPA is currently attacking our Rochester
and Milton uh we know for sure that we
have violated something or at least they
claim to have VI that the towns and
cities have Rochester and Milton have
violated some part of what they claim to
be but we can't tell you exactly which
part and we've been working on this for
quite some time and getting answers out
of the EPA has been incredibly difficult
so my constituents have demanded this
and I normally don't work in the
environmental side of things but uh when
constituents demand something you have
to do it uh especially when they do it
in in mass and they seem to have pretty
good reason to back up they what they're
angry
about so I'd love to give you a
breakdown of the totality of events that
have led to this spill but it's not
really that simple uh it's very easy to
see that the towns are getting attacked
by the EPA and we're not entire but it's
it's much more difficult to explain
exactly why that's the case um
so it seems to be related to a snail in
the Great
Bay um so there is the claim that the
EPA is making is that Knight nitrogen
from from the raced water treatment
plant in Milton is going into the Salmon
Falls River and killing a specific
species of snail um they they've made
the same claim for every community that
is on that River working from the Great
Bay
up uh
so the amount of evidence that's
available for this claim is seems to be
very very scant uh accessing it has been
very very difficult and the EPA is an
organization that notoriously loves to
overstep their statutory Authority so
from such shaky grounds they demand that
Milton a town of 4,500 people either
build a brand new wastewater treatment
plant even though they haven't really
proven that we're the source of the
nitrogen or build a giant pipe all the
way from our septic to Rochester for
treatment which would require it going
through mountains and granite and things
like that which obviously we cannot
afford uh Rochester already had their
hit with this same alleged issue we're
not sure that the actual issue is real
but uh they claim that uh or they have
had issues uh regarding contracts that
they've been forced to sign by the EPA
um which I believe representative Penza
will be talking about in more detail um
Dover is still suffering from uh issues
related to this alleged nitrogen
increase that is allegedly killing the
snail
um and that was recently seen in their
rainwater tax that if anybody is you
know any representatives from Dober
would probably be tracking that issue as
well uh so you may be wondering why I
nullify the entirety of the EPA based on
this um I'm going to be filing an
amendment to narrow the focus of the
bill uh but uh we needed to have
something to start with uh the first
portion of this bill is the meat and
potatoes of it uh but we are still
trying to figure out what specific parts
of the EPA we have to nli in order to
solve this problem um because all we can
do at the state level is is nullify we
don't have the ability to change how the
EPA does business H so if if you think
it's Overkill I don't think so um other
people may think though but uh we we're
we're planning to narrow the focus and
so the per point right now is to try to
figure out what specifically we're going
after there's other things that are
wrong with the EPA outside of uh just
Milton Rochester Dober and every other
town on the Salmon Falls Rivers uh rain
water and things like that uh they're
alleged nitrogen um so the EPA is just
notorious for not doing anything right
like so you take uh if you might have
noticed that there's a lot of uh trucks
nowadays are a lot longer and larger
than they used to be that's because the
EPA has incentivized longer Vehicles
because the longer your vehicle is the
lower the standards for fuel for uh
emissions and so in order to meet those
emission standards standards instead of
building small light trucks that are
very fuel efficient like they used to do
in the '90s they make these massive
Behemoth go look at a Ford Ranger and
it's the size of a Ford F250 from
1995 that's just an example they also
destroyed gas jugs uh if you guys have
ever purchased a modern gas jug you
might notice that those gas jugs don't
actually work you cannot actually use
the gas jug to fill a vehicle um so you
fill it with gas you put it in and it
doesn't work just splashes all over the
place that's because they have spill
resistant uh gas jug now that the EPA
has mandated that everybody uses even
though the old ones were perfectly fine
and worked great and nowadays you can't
use a gas jug without Hardware
modifications uh you also may have heard
about the recent Supreme Court ruling in
regards to how the EPA was overstepping
their statutory Authority when it came
to defining Wetlands um and that just
show shows that they do in fact overstep
their statutory Authority um and this is
in fact an actual problem that actually
exists when it comes to how how uh
bureaucracies will interpret the letter
of the law in a way that gives them more
power at the expense of uh the average
citizen so uh what I'm trying to what
we're trying to do is we need time to
actually figure out what specific aspect
of the EPA we need to nullify and so for
that purpose I would like you guys to
please don't itail the bill until we
have the amendment actually in front of
you um in the meantime yes this is a
very very wide Bill uh hopefully it made
some noise and got some attention and
now we can maybe get some answers to the
questions we were asking um and uh we
have a SE we have a couple more people
who are going to be testifying on this
bill um thank you very much okay thank
you question representative sofikitis
and I would also say I have a pink pink
card from representative Penza um so I
am requesting that you please leave your
table and sit in the audience As You Are
not eligible then to ask
questions no not not in not outside
out okay um I'm sorry representative
sopak kidus go ahead hi yes good morning
um it's have you or your group or your
constituents worked with our federal
delegation uh not directly uh they don't
like me because of uh party affiliation
I don't think they would return my
emails i' I've T tried to talk to them
about other things I uh they you know
they have our whole other song and dance
that they have to deal with thank you I
don't I don't think that if so if we did
determine exactly what part of the EPA
and what part of their statutory
Authority they are allows them to go
after our town in such a way uh and we
asked our federal delegation that that
would be great if they wanted to help I
just didn't uh expect them
to okay repres pres Murray thank you
madam chair um thank you for taking my
question I do have a question um has
there been no information or letters
from the EPA to any any of your town
municipalities Watershed agencies
notifying of
the problem so uh representative Burnham
is another uh co-sponsor on this bill
unfortunately uh due to the short notice
she wasn't able to make it here today I
believe that she would be able to
provide all that she has because she is
also a selectman in the town of
Milton representative
Dy uh yes uh thank you madam chair um I
have a question and a uh correction I
believe the in the uh the um the item
that you were talking about regarding
the EPA and overstepping their boundary
boundaries I believe that came before
The Supreme Court and that was sacket
versus the EPA Okay so it was the
Supreme Court of the United States that
made um the um
determination okay that the EPA was uh
overstepping its boundaries in fact
every
environmental um
organization uh was not only stunned by
that um decision um but they're figuring
out how they might be able to circumvent
it because wetlands are very important
to our environment so that's that's the
comment I wanted to make um the question
I have is um in the fiscal note it says
that I believe the dees says that we
would be losing about $150 million per
year in federal funds my question is is
how would you be replacing um that
money uh so as I said the amendment is
uh a work in progress and is likely to
make make the fiscal note uh relatively
meaningless thank you representative ger
thank you very much Madam chair and
thank you for taking my question I want
to follow up on uh something
representative Duty just uh referred to
you you've spoken about a recent Supreme
Court ruling about overreach uh by the
EPA uh I don't know if representative
Duty referred to one case are you
familiar with the June 20 2022 ruling by
the Supreme Court in West Virginia
versus the
EPA I have sacket versus uh the EPA up
but I don't have that one up no okay so
West Virginia versus the EPA was also a
uh the Court ruled that EPA had
overstepped its bounds but even in that
case the the conservative Supreme Court
who ruled 6 to3 against the EPA didn't
even raise a whisper of the question
that somehow the agency was
unconstitutional so my question to you
is is your judgment as it is expressed
in this bill that the EPA is
unconstitutional meant to somehow uh
take precedence over the Supreme Court
which has not raise the
constitutionality of the existence of
that
department I believe that the Supreme
Court doesn't uh proactively go out and
create cases on their own uh someone
else has to create a case and then it
has to go up through the judicial
process in order to get to them I
followup follow up uh but they could
have in that case not only uh restricted
the rul making of of the EPA but
actually ruled on the constitutionality
of any actions by the EPA they didn't do
that but I'll ask you uh also just as a
final followup uh to this question about
the
constitutionality uh if you're
specifically familiar with familiar with
sections two and three of article two of
the
Constitution let me pull it
up well I I'll just I'll say you you
could take a look at it these are the
articles in the Constitution which
establish the right of the Office of the
President to to established executive
departments this uh EPA was established
by law uh which was signed in by uh
President Nixon uh and so executive
departments uh the fact that the EPA
does not exist within the Constitution
does not make it unconstitutional those
two sections in the Constitution
establish the right of the executive
branch to establish executive department
under of law uh I would say that if
would they then be able to just make any
Department that they wish the
Constitutional Authority is very limited
you are only allowed to make to the
federal government is only allowed to do
that which is explicitly described in
the Constitution and things that pertain
to that uh the so I I don't think that
that's relevant in this specific case
Congress has given the power to
establish uh to pass those laws and it
was passed by the president to create an
executive branch which is uh how the
Constitution
works if that's your opinion that's your
opinion
no
no representative NAB thank you madam
chair thank you for testifying today um
I wonder if you have worked with Dees on
this at all I mean I respect the fact
that your towns have a problem and this
has been very stressful for towns that
have to upgrade their wastewater
treatment plants and it is an expense
it's an expense if you're an ms4 permit
Town um but it it feels like there are
other ways to try and get at this
outside of nullifying our relationship
with EPA as a state so I just wonder um
yeah so you worked with thees on this
issue at all or gotten answers out of
them at least I mean I feel like there's
a there's a communication issue going on
here in addition to the financial
obligations yes it's right we are having
communication issues as well the I
believe that Claudine Burnham who was
unfortunately not able to be here today
has been doing that and that's been
something that she's been spearheading
as part of her her role as a selectman
in town um so I personally have not
however it has been getting done or at
least uh as best as as possible
followup represent na thank you I just
this isn't really a question but an
offer that I work with the Great Bay
National estaran research Reserve quite
a bit and Dees on Great Bay issues so if
I could be helpful in that role of
getting answers for you I'd be happy to
help because I I respect that you have a
problemes thank you very
much thank you madam chair um just to be
clear listening to your testimony uh
you're not trying to nullify the EPA
this was just a placeholder Bill until a
future Amendment could be filed is that
correct uh pretty much yeah thank you
okay representative
Duty uh yes thank you uh you had
mentioned um that there were a number of
your constituents that had contacted you
and therefore you felt you were forced
uh to do something um could you tell me
approximately how many of those
constituents had contacted
you I don't count but it's significant
enough that the number is not easily
attain AED off hand 50 100 a th000 2,000
well there's only 4,500 people in the
town of Milton and that's what I'm
trying to get at so for so are we
talking about 50% of the population I
don't think it'd be 50% because I don't
think 50% of the population pays enough
attention to town meetings to uh it's a
significant number okay thank you
representative kraton you had a
question uh yes Madam chair thank you
yeah just in line um with the previous
question what about uh the Attorney
General have they been involved in this
I mean clearly a lot of things that
would fall into their
baileywick have been mentioned in this
bill uh I I'm I I don't know if they uh
if any of us actually have reached out
to the attorney general if uh you think
that that's an appropriate Avenue then
we can if we're talking about
constitutionality of an agency and their
ability to create laws and rules within
new state of New Hampshire that would I
think that would be another Avenue oh
thank
you um representative Murray thank you
madam chair and thank you for taking my
question I'm I'm curious to know whether
or not you have explored all of the
potential impacts to either this bill
version or potential amendments that you
plan to bring forward would have on
funding mechanisms outside of just even
General Appropriations but also grant
funding applications if um there were
some sort of relationship change between
how we interact with the EPA um
so it it isn't my intention to
uh I I kind of don't want to go into the
weeds of that uh I believe there's
probably significant disagreement on
what the actual role of taking federal
funds should be and whether we should be
taking federal funds for X Y or z uh
so rather
than trying
to i' I'd rather just not answer that
question I
guess represent Bixby okay so um just uh
thinking about the time here and I think
that um it's clear that further
questions about the bill as it's been
presented to us so far don't actually
that make that much sense it's
considering doing a a substantial
Amendment on it uh but I just wanted to
make sure that you're aware that this is
an early bill so uh we have to have it
voted out of committee by um
mid-February uh so I was wondering when
you expect that you might be able to
present us with an amendment that we
could consider unfortunately if I do not
have uh an amendment by the time this
bill is due out of committee then I'm
sorry I tried I I I I wish I could give
you a a deadline but it it's it's it's
it's Hardo so far and um if
unfortunately an amendment is not out by
the time you're uh you have to vote on
this or before it has to get kicked out
of committee um I I tried my best but um
it is what it is at that point I
hopefully hopefully we can avoid that
whole issue by having the amendment to
you before
then thank
you okay any other questions otherwise
we can move on to uh we have four other
folks who'd like to speak I have uh
representative
Belcher who has requested two
minutes okay um I'd like to restrict it
also we have we're running out of time
so I'd like to restrict it to uh three
minutes
please sorry I just to
okay so I just want to be clear that
um you know when I saw this bill I I I
you know I was kind of taken off guard
um I don't support this bill in this in
its current fashion in any way so this
this this came up because um you know of
course it's gotten a lot of social media
attention uh negative you know they say
negative a better negative attention is
better than no attention um I appreciate
uh representative Granger for bringing
this forward so if you can see what I
passed out and uh it was copied and so
there's definitely um some people have
some copies that you can't even really
tell this is where this all started
where I got involved and it was from
it's now from several constituents so in
Rochester during our city council uh
this conservation law Foundation type
pseudo committee uh presented to the
Rochester city council um at the time
Senator gray was still sitting on that
Council he was floored by this um there
was so much feedback basically what's
happening is um a group of city managers
from Dover and Rochester uh and
Portsmouth uh decided on pretty much
this rain tax is what it is and um so
just to give you kind of an and there's
a big contract here and I'll send the
committee everything that they need on
this um the good thing is is that this
went through Dover first and the Dover
City Council um actually rejected it but
this is the problem they rejected it and
there's another constituent that's going
to be talking about this she's the one
that got me involved in this and she's
from do she's from Dover so the city
voted 6 to3 to end the rain tag ta but
there's still a contract that was signed
that you can see it from Mr joyle on
32621 with the EPA is this contract now
void and so the City attorney writes
back and
says this settlement agreement is still
in effect and EPA was not a party to
that settlement agreement the mam Group
which is the you know it's up here it
tells you what the name is it's mam is
the abbreviation meets periodically you
may find ma'am the ma'am uh website here
of interest and then I'll send you that
so you guys can have that so it there's
basically like an intermunicipal body
that is that is passing something where
that's taxation without representation
these these folks that have huge pieces
of property like the person that's going
to speak is going to be severely
impacted if you have rental property if
you have if you just have a lot of land
you're going to get hit and it's it's
crazy if you look at this document um on
page
11 that you T there are literally four
city managers that that decided this um
I know that the constituents that's
going to speak to you contacted the
committee it was in the summertime and
and um and this has just not had enough
visibility at all people should be
screaming about this um and I talked to
the city council in Rochester after that
meeting and um everybody was very
blindsided the audience was crazy they
they just couldn't even believe what
they were hearing so and the City of
Rochester is actually paying I haven't
received that information yet from my
91a um paying someone to be on this
Council type committee that is
deciding this um this whole agreement uh
once I send you this electronically you
will see where the tax impact is they
give a proposed tax impact which is in
here too it's hard to read on here but
that's kind of where we're at there's
there's a huge um overreach at this
point and um and and that's why that's
why um and I don't know if we can pull
an amendment together somehow to to make
this type of stuff stop but um we're
going to do everything possible so thank
you thank you
okay um I would also like to call um
representative vure next you've
requested two minutes to
speak thank you madam chair members of
the committee good morning um I'm going
to present a little a little bit of a
different view of this bill my view of
it is a little bit narrower than I think
what you've heard but I think it's well
founded um so what is this bill not
first of all this bill is not telling
the US Congress that it does not have
the authority to make law that's not
what this is congressional laws related
to environment and agriculture would not
be voided by this
bill recently as I'm sure you guys have
discussed a little bit already uh the
Supreme Court has made significant cuts
to the previously existing doctrine of
of Chevron Defence this concept that uh
that Congress May delegate its lawmaking
authorities to executive agencies has
seen significant
cutbacks and that is the primary focus I
see in this
bill now in recent years the laws
carrying both civil and criminal
penalties promulgated by by executive
agencies has dwarfed those laws that
have been passed by Congress and that's
part of the rationale that's been shown
by scotus in rolling back Chev on
Defence I would note that the EPA in
particular has an extremely spotty track
record from classifying part-year ankle
deep streams as navigable waterways and
devastating farming activity to the
catastrophic poisoning of the Animus
River in Colorado which was purely due
to dereliction and incompetence on the
part of this Federal
agency now we proposed this and I put my
name to this document not because I hate
the environment but because I love it
and I cherish it enough that I would
rather see this in the hands of New
Hampshire than in this Federal
agency now I'd also note that as far as
things I've heard and questions that
I've heard brought up there's nothing in
this document nothing in this in this
legislation that nullifies Congress
there's also nothing that nullifies the
enforcement capacity of the EPA when it
is acting according to laws passed by
Congress there's that's just not in here
anywhere it only addresses Rules
promulgated by the EPA outside of laws
that were passed by Congress and as such
I would disagree with the fiscal note
and I see no such reason that there
should be any law of finances as a
result of this Bill thank you
questions representative
Gera thank you madam chair and thank you
for taking my question representative so
uh I understand you know going back to
our discussion about recent uh Supreme
Court decisions regarding the scope of
of the EPA there's room for debate but
there's no question that the Supreme
Court has ruled on those when when you
just made reference to uh actions on the
part of the EPA that are outside of the
scope of the laws that are created by
Congress right that's a function is it
not for the for the judicial branch
which is exact L actually in in uh West
Virginia versus EPA uh the the court has
a a piece in which they talk about the
appropriateness of a Judicial decision
in cases that some people thought maybe
wasn't appropriate but in any event when
you're talking about rules that are
promulgated outside of the laws written
by
Congress is that not a judicial branch
issue rather than a legislative branch
issue no not at all I I think what
you're offering is a doctrine of
judicial Supremacy and this country was
not set up as a Judicial oligarchy it
was set up as a as three co-equal
branches that have each other in check
and I think when there's an error made
and I think originally Chevron Defence
was an error we as a federalist system
need to offer some push back can I
follow up you may follow up uh I would
just encourage you if you take a look at
again U uh West Virginia versus EPA that
is not the finding of the Supreme
Court okay representative dsy yes thank
you madam chair um representative beler
uh I attend a lot of conferences and I
attend a lot of webinars uh regarding
the environment a couple of things are
you aware that we that New Hampshire is
routinely called the
Alabama of the Northeast because of our
environmental um positions are you aware
of the fact that we had passed bills in
1995 okay to set in place certain
targets to improve the environment and
we have not yet met those bills the
targets of those bills from
1995 are you aware that just this past
year we updated um our our I believe it
was our climate or our our Dees a solid
waste management plan that was due to be
updated in
2003 so for uh for uh members of this uh
uh the House of Representatives to
consider the fact that New Hampshire
would do better uh than the EPA on
environmental standards uh I think they
should look at the record are you aware
of that uh U thank you that's there was
a lot of questions I'll do my best to
address them I think two answers first I
I would not be on board with um any sort
of negative connotations or slandering
of our of our Southern uh fellow
citizens in Alabama um as far as New
Hampshire and our track record um I'm
sure there's always going to be room for
improvement but I I would ask the the
citizens of Colorado how they feel about
the M disaster and the poisoning of that
major river that was directly
attributable to the
EPA okay representative
brog thank you madam chair uh
representative beler are you aware that
since 200 18 the EPA spent millions of
dollars on ammunition firearms and other
military grade equipment and are you
comfortable with the EPA being a lethal
arm of the federal government so I have
I have a a basic understanding I I don't
know every point of order Madam chair I
I'd just like to stay focused on the
construct of the bill yes uh I would
agree with that I think we should uh
stay with the uh
with the within the confines of this
legislation well if if I if I may real
quick just offer a supporting um I mean
this this bill does regard the
enforcement mechanism of the EPA which
is a coercive mechanism that often times
can but you will be bringing an
amendment to narrow this bill down as I
understand I I believe that was offered
I won't be bringing that amend myself I
was offering my more narrow General
reading of the bill as it exists thank
you representative Bixby you had a
question yeah um I'd just like to point
out for the committee that our purpose
here is to ask questions that illuminate
the specifics of the bill and I uh and I
it is not this is not the time to offer
our own personal opinions about it
that's what we do in work sessions so uh
please make sure that the that you're
asking questions that are uh really
trying to illuminate details of the bill
that are not clear from the bill itself
thank you thank you okay um
representative kto thank you madam chair
and thank you representative for taking
my question um as you heard the
testimony um from representative Granger
about the snail um and I'm assuming
that's what we're talking about here I
understand um that you're looking at
this as more narrowly focused um
but do you feel that an amendment uh
should be brought forth um addressing
the specific issue um and how it affects
uh the Lively um hood of these
towns I would be perfectly happy to see
an amendment brought forward that
clarifies any language that we
collectively feel needs to be clarified
uh I I would note that my again my my
reading of the bill as it exists is a
bit narrower and I think that's well
founded in the actual language of the
bill
okay representative
Howard thank you madam chair um
representative belter I I read um sort
of quickly read the past report from
Dees and there was a mention of s Salmon
Falls in there and and mitigation
required for um I don't remember um
Milton being mentioned but um do do you
think that with the remediation for the
nitrogen and for the from this bill that
uh representative Granger mentioned be
um part of the P remediation that's
required that that the Das has has
pointed
out I'm sorry could you restate I'm not
sure I understand the question yeah so
um representative Granger mentioned that
that um nitrogen was the problem that
that the REM remediation was required
for that was going to cost Milton a lot
of a lot of money in Rochester um and I
think that this was also pulled out as
as a p um project
and um would they would those be tied
together as far as remediation
goes I I apologize I I don't see any any
direct reference to the nature of the
bill if if you want me to answer more
generally I I believe those are articles
that can and should be um in the hands
of the State of New Hampshire and I
think we can do that as a legislature to
make sure these things get done
right no I think we need to move on here
and I would like to to have uh thank you
for your testimony and have
representative Horgan come and speak uh
you have outlined three minutes we are
already over our time so I would like to
get through this quickly because we have
another bill that we need to do before
lunch so I'm representing Timothy Horgan
I represent statford County District 10
which is the town of Durham which uh
directly uh which has uh well several
miles of Shoreline in Great Bay so we're
actually uh the whole town drains into
Great Bay and we do uh we do spend a lot
of money on uh Wastewater uh treatment
and but that's one of our
responsibilities as a town and Milton
you know maybe 15 miles upstream and
maybe a town of only 4500 but that is uh
one of its responsibilities and I think
Banning the EPA from the state doesn't
really help it meet those
responsibilities um we certainly could
do a better job with it I was not aware
of the issue with um I mean I hear a lot
about pollution in Durham my
constituents have never uh said anything
about uh nitrogen or an endangered
species of snail I don't even know what
the species of snail is it might have
been helpful if we'd got some
information about exactly what the
species was of snail but
um so I uh but certainly certainly my
community you know fully supports uh
fully supports not polluting Great Bay
and that's uh you know water um
everything's in interconnected is even
um you know the founding father's notice
it's mentioned that you know caring for
waterways especially navigable waterways
of Salmon Falls is explicitly you know
part the federal government's powers
from the beginning it's even like
there's even some Federalist Papers
about the environmental issues this is
nothing new so I was mostly reacting
just to the bill um the bill as for
presented I the hypothetical amendment I
don't know if nullifying part of the EPA
is any better idea or any more
Constitution than nullifying the whole
thing which is what the original Bill
said um the frankly I didn't understand
the Constitutional Amendment the
original bill at all I think I even
joked that it sounds like it was written
by chat GPT but that's um but to get
down we don't have the power to
unilaterally ban the EPA or any other
Federal agency or even to partially ban
it from the state and also even if we
had the power which we don't it's a
terrible idea um as I already said you
know as I as I said you know water
pollution uh is a legitimate problem
even if we don't have the EPA even if we
suceed of the United States we still
have to deal things including nitrogen
runoff
um the issue with this snail and I um I
mean I know there are endangered species
here in here in New Hampshire I'm not
familiar with any snail in Great Bay but
I it's plausible there is one um you
know it's probably not just about the
snail it's about the whole ecosystem so
the issues with that snail would be uh
they would be sort of a symbol of what's
wrong with the uh something that's wrong
the entire ecosystem and certainly
restricting nitrogen runoff is like a
legitimate way of of addressing those
problems so and the fiscal note has two
pages long sign the first person to
basically defend the EPA here of it
shows many many things that it does for
the state that are good for the state to
the best of my knowledge the dep
Environmental Services likes having them
here they don't want them to like they
don't want to get rid of them and also
if we focus on the EPA there's other
agencies like for example the Army Corps
of Engineers for which I used to work
many years ago for a few years who also
have jurisdiction over that so you're
not you're not banning all the uh if you
get rid of even you ban the EPA or
partially you've still got other
agencies you have to deal with so I
think um I think this bill's inexpedient
to legislate the uh Amendment um I as I
said it doesn't exist I haven't seen it
but I don't think I could vote for that
either so I I think the best thing to do
is um find it inexpedient to legislate
or you could try to have an interim
study maybe to get a little bit more
clarity about what these issues are
because I don't um I didn't quite
understand the explanation of what the
problem was except in so far as Milton
uh may need to build a new wastewater
treatment plant which representan can
you wrap up please yes so I think I've
covered everything so uh I think this
bill is not worth pursuing and you
should either in expedient the
legislator possibly interim study but
probably just itl is probably the best
thing to do and at least at least now I
do understand why I was in this
committee because I first read it I said
this sounds more like the kind of thing
they send to state federal or
legislative Administration but at least
I see why it's here but yes thanks thank
you and our last pink card is um for uh
Julie
Porter Welcome to our committee and I
hope you can be brief no unfortunately
not well we have other bills that
understand but I'm a citizen I'm
probably the only one in this room that
represents a farm okay so I I implore
you to listen to me we are listening I I
just would like you to I'll make it as
brief as I can this could go on for days
but here we go several years ago I
learned about the city of DOA work to
implement a Rain Tax that led me here
today unfortunately due to the storm and
my plow truck breaking down I didn't
have any copies to pass out but I will
email the information I have because it
might answer a lot of questions the Rain
Tax or stormw water utility I'm going to
expose you to the EPA overreach without
cause or proof to strangle hold New
Hampshire people and natural resources
there's not enough time to get into all
the details today the email that I'll
send includes just a few of the links
involved in this effort which links
includes dozen more links I mean it
could go on you could spend years trying
to research this
stuff I believe you'll find as I did
there's no actual science to back any of
this up just assumptions my focus is on
farming but many other professions
people in natural resources are at risk
farming big and small has always been
the New Hampshire way the lands have
flourished with food and livestock to
feed us through time yet the EPA has
only been around for 50 years while
farmers are trying to keep New Hampshire
natural resources EA comes along and
does the opposite UNH extensions spent
over a 100 years in developing best
management practices for best yields and
the ecosystem one of those is a buffer
zone for Wetlands it's known to filter
possible contaminant runoff no one wants
dirty water no one wants dirty air no
one so why has the government become so
blinded by the special interest project
they can't see the forest through the
trees since when Lodge corporations can
permit to dredge and fill Wetlands
overnight and the little guy gets the
shaft for having large large and perf
surfaces pole bars and driveways the EPA
has become an arm of big government to
do the bidding of lobbyists so when it
comes to the actual environment they
fail the land and the people how someone
in DC or even Boston possibly can have a
clue what lands and water in New
Hampshire need by sitting in a desk
looking at satellite imagery that tells
only half the truth of the land they
show no bmps or even a homeowner using a
rain barrel and overa we just put to
rest for now the first in the state Rain
Tax or storm water utility
this effort was forced upon taxpayers to
appease the maam which was mentioned
before the EPA and the clf which I mean
these these go on forever there's a
million groups involved in this so if
you want to delve into it I'll send you
the links contract dated 321 with Port
Smith overa Rochester City basically
tried to
enact a restrictive unjustified burden
on property owners and effect to help
pay for costs associated by the
EPA contract and shortfall in the city
budget for sewer duver overa development
the impact to small homes was minimal
but to Farms Apartments businesses and
nonprofit it was tens of thousands of
dollars per year my farm alone was
$335,000 a year in storm water Rain
Tax sorry the tax is going to be double
tax we're already taxing our square
footage and this tax includes imper
surfaces even nonprofits weren't exempt
in fact the only exemption was State
highways it died because it was done
clandestine no one believed it no one
seemed to pay attention until the day
before the vote people woke up showed up
schooled the city council in ways of
notice illegal taxation the mayor and
sever city council members agonized and
voted six to3 to kill the tax there was
no there was so much wrong with this
effort it would be a nightmare for
property owners and the rest of us
several of the items on the epa's list
for those SE were one of those items
there there's hundreds of them was they
wanted us to replace our septics Sy I'm
on septic they wanted us to replace our
septic systems and replace them with
nitrogen-free systems yet the the New
Hampshire Dees has not approved a
nitrogen fee septic system my property
rates over 4,000 TSS which I believe is
total surface solubles which is
phosphorus and nitrogen while my
neighbor who applies p pesticides
regularly to their lawn is about 200 so
you can see the vast difference mainly
because I have a large farm a lot of
pole buildings this number is each
Property Owners impacted the link to all
SE Coast towns in each land impact I'll
send that to you as well overreach the
EPA wants the city to pay $20 million
for a new wastewater treatment plan and
don't even know if it'll work the
efforts the city has done to nearly
eliminate nitrates from discharge into
the rivers is about 90% same with
Rochester
this is according to New Hampshire DS
I've spoken to tons of people over there
yet the EPA is demanding a $20 million
new plant they don't even know if
nitrogen is the issue part of the claim
comes from the epa's newest pet project
nitrogen like CO2 nitrogen is one of the
basic elements to Growing food if you're
a farmer you know
this in 2006 there was a hundred-year
flood or Mother's Day flood in the Sea
Coast I'll have photos that I'll send
you this massive flood caused the
wastewater treatment plants all along
the river in the SE Coast to overflow
effluent into Great Bay you can see that
on the chart from the nhdes spike since
testing started in 200000 to 2016 the
nitrogen levels have plummeted and wred
themselves that's what happens with a
fast moving tidal River according to the
EPA it isn't enough yet there have been
zero studies to determine what Eel Grass
I'll get to Eel Grass in a minute to the
Bay decline no one study has been done
to determine if it is in fact nitrogen
or something else entirely or maybe it's
the natural natural life cycle of Eel
Grass no one seems to know or care so
let's call it nitrogen all the
environmentalists will be happy wrong
this issue is far more compelling I've
asked everyone all the
Departments to the agencies what if
nitrogen tanks in the bay okay big SC
what if if we go too far with this whole
nitrogen thing what if it tanks what are
you going to do are you going to they
don't they don't have anything in place
nothing zero zip NADA to test if it goes
too low and they have no fail safe to
what to do with it if it does go too low
and again this the city and the maam are
actually starting a study to try to find
answers as to why and I don't know what
about the snail but according to them
it's the Eel
Grass I own a farm in do I've had it for
30 years I grew up on dairy farms and
Lee we maintained a healthy balance with
nature we know how the land works and
how it efficiently make the land prosper
in your Wildlife rural character
gentrification small farms were
encouraged now Farms are the
devil when I found about about the
nitrogen I had my property tested
because again I'm like well I certainly
don't want to harm my land I don't want
to harm the bay I don't want to harm
anything so I had my property tested on
a storm water day off the roof zero
excess nitrogen all the way to my my
retention pond with 52 houses drain in
including my manure pit on and on and on
zero excess nitrogen I go all the way to
the Bellamy Reservoir which is pouth
water supply tested there zero excess
nitrogen I don't know what I don't know
what they're doing but anyway let's talk
about eelgrass according to the
authorities Eel Grass is declining some
of the things listed to the decline are
humans changing conditions run off
Wastewater Etc so the EPA others go
after the wastewater treatment plans but
are absolutely sure they are the cause
if eone is a factor in the Bay's Health
then why are both boat stumping raw
sewage in the bay while golf courses of
beautiful Lawns exempt why is the ra to
front development allowed at all why are
The Lawns allowed to add harmful
pesticides and live on the
bay the folks who on Waterfront boats
don't want to be treated like the rest
of us I guess I don't know why no one
speaks up and why I do I deeply care for
every spotted wood Blanding turtle on my
property the owls the plants the spotted
striped salamanders the veral pools
which are many that team with life the
deer the Moose we are fortunate to have
on our land the trees we are the second
largest Pine in the county 30 years of
being a caretaker and you'll allow some
suit in Boston to take this away because
basically that kind of money we'll be
selling it to development I don't want
to I want it for my
grandchildren but some suit in Boston's
driving this bus I have no
idea and and this whole area if this
kind of stuff goes on and it is is going
into all the towns including durm all
anyone that's on a river in New
Hampshire basically is going to get some
kind of nitrogen thing from the
EPA so getting New Hampshire Dees in
control without the overhand at EPA is a
start maybe we can heal what's left of
our
lands before you know before Farmers
have to sell just going to give you a
couple timelines I'm almost done um my
land was farmed in the 400 years ago and
for colonies 1640 New Hampshire was
established 1776 UNH 1866 extension 1917
now extensions if any of you are farmers
know how valuable extension is to us
which is another one last point I want
to bring up the EPA is
1970 so to me there's a big disconnect
there they they aren't working with
us so when it comes to extension
everybody wants to pull nitrogen out of
the water we send our so samples to
extension every year they tell us to put
nitrogen back in so somebody please tell
me what is going on I I would really
like to know what the EPA what all these
people are doing I go to the city I talk
to them their hands are tied the city of
Dober is paying millions of dollars or
whatever on studies for the EPA to make
them
happy the more I get into this the more
my head hurts and all I want to to is do
my farm and and this kind of stuff comes
up and I'm not going to be able to do it
anymore neither are there the other
Farmers that don't even know about this
CA has only run around for 50 years
where farming been here for hundreds the
land I occupied steuart is Native
American land we need better studies
before jumping into possible
irreversible programs have our own New
Hampshire Dees and control of New
Hampshire natural resources is a start
again I'm not sitting here telling you
that I'm against the environment it's
the opposite and I do think that there's
a problem and a disconnect with those
suits in Boston telling us people in New
Hampshire about my flood plane I'm sorry
but it's it's bad and we fought this and
no one would listen and that's why I'm
here today because I don't know if
you're going to listen to me or not but
I'll tell you a whole lot of Wildlife
and whatever in my property is going to
go because I can't afford it I can't
afford it anymore Dober is like one of
the most expensive towns and the money
they've spent on this EPA juggling thing
with with SE sep sewers and Wastewater
treatment plants and on and on and
Rochester is dealing with the same
thing I really don't know so thank you I
appreciate your time thank you any
questions okay representative
Penza oh yeah you can't you can't
because you testified sorry
representative Duty that's why you're
supposed to be sitting over there yes um
thank you thank you um uh Madam is your
property uh in current use yes so you're
Al you're already getting a reduced tax
rate in order for you to G your property
is that correct yes okay thank you
what's that got to do I'd like to know
what that has to do with it no it's not
your every Farm in New Hampshire's on
current use honey every one it's not
your perview to ask questions I can't
ask questions no we are asking questions
from your test excuse me I never done
this before I want to be home on my farm
I don't want no worries representative
kulan you had a question oh yeah first
of all I'd like to you know say I think
that you've incurred a great Injustice
in your way over tax and it sounds like
you in your town and everyone else is
being bullied by the EPA and I think it
sounds like you think that maybe we
might consider waiting for an amendment
to fix and overhaul this bill to help
people like you and Farmers because
that's what we're supposed to be doing
on this committee is caring about
farmers and you sound like you are one
so yeah I am one awesome thank you
representative Murray thank you madam
chair and and maybe this is a question
for the original sponsor or or or
yourself I don't I don't know but
forgive me if you can't answer it then
somebody else can fine um I I was
looking through some of the other
information that was provided to us and
it looks like there were according to a
letter that was included in some of the
testimony there are 13 New Hampshire
Wastewater dischargers that were being
considered from the US Environmental
Protection agency and it sounds to me
like based on your information and some
of the others that we don't really have
a full complement of information here no
and and that's my point to every
everyone that even even to the city that
there's not enough study done to know
exactly why eelgrass is dying is it is
it a natural cycle is it something else
entirely they don't know they absolutely
you cannot I've looked through every
single document after every single
person and not one one person can tell
me why what's going on in the bay and
why so they just put a name on it it's
nitrogen it's nitrogen and C then
cascaded a bunch of other stuff but
there there are groups out there and and
I guess do told me because I met with
them last week the City attorney said
that they I think at the mam group or
one of the one of the groups is going to
actually begin studying why because we
you know Dober can't incur and they
don't don't even know if it's going to
work they don't even know of these
things that the EPA is setting up for us
are going to work so they're working
closely with New Hampshire Dees and you
know I've talked to them at length I
don't agree with everything but some of
the I think it's better
local I don't know that your question
but representative ger thank you madam
chair and I want to thank you for taking
the time out of your your work to come
and talk to us today this is great to
have some very specific context about
what is happening in your community so
thank you uh do you know uh it would
seem to me that in addition to D Dees
that the Attorney General's office might
be a place to go uh to see you know what
protections might be uh made available
from the state uh so do you know uh what
Outreach has been done to the attorney
general to see where they might be able
to help you the community I sent to this
gentleman here I've sent to the New
Hampshire attorney general formella I
believe is his name I sent his office
the this information about what we were
going through in do demanding answers
and got nothing zip I'm sorry to hear
that well thank you for answering my
question um you do you have a written
copy of your testimony at all I can
email that thank you we would appreciate
it uh representative saitis and I hope
that we can wrap this up because uh
we're running late here thank you I just
want to make sure that you understand
that you're welcome here and we we're
glad that you've come I've been on this
committee for several sessions and this
is the first I've heard of it and so I'm
I'm delighted that you came today thank
you as am I thank you okay uh any other
questions
comments I it's it's a rabbit hole thank
you all you um I would like to get the
blue sheet um I've also been informed
that the uh online um comments on this
for were in support of this bill and 44
were in opposition of this
bill
four and 44 were in
opposition online yep in the blue sheet
nobody has written anything on this so
with that I'm going to close this
hearing for hb1
1294 and we are running late um this is
supposed to be our lunchtime but
hopefully we can get through this next
one very quickly so I invite um
representative Dan Maguire to come and
introduce HB
1626 thank you very much Madam chair
members of the committee for the record
my name is Dan Maguire I represent the
town of Epsom this year I happen to be
the chair of the joint committee on
dedicated funds um this is a committee
which um reviews all the dedicated funds
on a five-year cycle and um makes
recommendations of what what's to be
done with those funds and this year we
we did a fifth of the funds um which
included the Department of Agriculture
and this bill House Bill 1626 is the
result of the committee's work and it's
it's not exactly technical changes but
it's it's the next best thing you know
this is the kind of Bill that that
frequently just gets passed on consent
with
no not much changes the biggest thing in
the bill um related to the Department of
Agriculture is the uh the beginning two
sections that have to do with the dog
license fees so currently
$2.50 of the dog license fees goes to
the Department of Agriculture for um uh
$2 for the um spay and neuter program
and 50 cents for the veterinary
diagnostic laboratory and what we
noticed with these two particular funds
is one was growing so so they weren't
using all the money for that one the
other one was shrinking so it needed a
little more money and the department
asks us to change it change the ratio to
$1.75 for the spay and neuter and 75
cents for the veterinary diagnostic
laboratory that's the kind of stuff this
this bill is all about so I'm happy to
answer questions I brought one copy of
our um our report for your for your
clerk um but I can get other copies if
you if you really want them thank you
representative Bixby yes uh thank you
for taking my question um so I uh just
talked with representative Aly last
night who uh was did not really want to
come in to testify for two minutes today
and I understand uh so uh she gave me to
understand that uh there are two portion
essentially two aspects of this bill one
has to do with the repealing of a lot of
dedicated funds the other has to do with
the dog license fees and she indicated
that um that the dog license fee was the
only part that really was connected to
what we're doing on this committee
because the other is pretty much a ways
and means issue uh so is is that correct
yes okay uh so um essentially uh What uh
this bill is asking us to determine is
whether it makes sense to uh make give
the Diagnostic lab a little bit more
money and the spay and neuter fund which
is because it's so effective not needed
as much anymore a little bit less money
is that correct okay y sounds good to me
and you could read the dedicated funds
report which shows you the balances and
how they're changing over the years all
that stuff thank you or not yeah but
that's what we did so
all
right um representative NAB thank you
madam chair thank you for coming in
today um I it might be outside of our
purview but I just wonder if you could
speak to part two number three what's
changing there with the hunting fishing
and trapping nothing's changing it says
repealed and okay that's previous unless
that's a highlighted I don't see
anything highlighted that would address
a repeal in that section or
we it says it's repealed and react I
didn't know if something was changing
there or not yeah this is a case where
um there was some dedicated F some
something going into a dedicated fund um
which I guess was um sort of unused and
and the fish and game department just
wanted it in their J in their their
normal fund right so they you know that
that's kind of what's going on there all
right thank
you okay any other questions
trying to get that okay repres I just
have a comment which is I had been
considering executing this now exe
executing this today because it's just
so straightforward but I think that
given the time we should just put it on
the list for our other execs in a couple
of weeks no problem thank you uh I also
have thank you for your
testimony representative Maguire uh I
have uh one another person who asked for
two minutes to speak natch gra from nhma
welcome to environment
agriculture thank you madam chair n gra
for the municipal Association um as
representative McGuire uh noted this is
a very there are a lot of parts to this
bill um the only part that we are really
concerned about is the uh apportionment
of the fees the dog licensing fees that
are kept by the municipality versus uh
that go to the state assuming that I
read this
correctly um although someone should
certainly check my math um
the there would be a decrease in the
total dog registration fee of of dog
owners over 65 by a quarter so it go
from $2 to
.75 and there would be an increase in
the amount of the going to the
veterinary diagnostic Library by a
quarter 50 or 75 cents instead of 50 and
that's not paid by those over 75 uh over
65 according to what I believe I
understand how this is a portioned um so
I went back and looked at uh 2023 is HB
585 um the fiscal note for that that was
F out by the Department of Agriculture
indicating they get uh $2 per license um
and approximately $400,000 per year from
that total um which leaves me to believe
there are about 200,000 registered dogs
in the state of New
Hampshire um because there was no
increase in the amount of the uh overall
fee by a quarter um and there was a
decrease by those over 65 by a quarter
um I estimated that quarter would cost
about $50,000 per year um that's about
$50,000 per year that would not be kept
at the local level so it' be a a
decrease local revenues by $50,000 a
year across the entire State I recognize
that overall in the scheme of things
that isn't very much but we do have a a
policy to oppose uh decreases in Revenue
um that would negatively impact
taxpayers because that would have to be
made up in some way which is probably
local property
taxes representative Bixby okay so
um the I think that the issue is really
stem from uh the a change in the revenue
intended for towns I think that it it
has to do with the way that the UN
existing underlying law is is written
which is uh the when when the fees for
the DI Diagnostic lab were put in that
went to the Diagnostic lab were put in
it was done in a sort of clumsy way but
I think that um that in fact the changes
to the amounts going in and out uh are
really pretty are really a wash uh and
it just has to do with the way and and
what the the the changes don't uh have
to do with the actual amount going to
the towns and or um the towns still
retain the same amount of money that
they would
already like I said that's our only
concern and someone should double check
my math on that okay and and if you want
to touch base with me I can go over that
section law with you and and we can like
sort out where why it's confusing it's
quite it's quite complex as you know
thank you
thanks thank
you I do want to acknowledge that we did
receive a communication from Dr Steven
Crawford our state
veterinarian um which was sent to every
member of our committee um that
regarding HB 1626 neither commissioner
Jasper nor Dr Crawford uh would be able
to attend the hearing today but um they
both uh not as the Department's
testimony to support hb1
1626 and
um I just wanted to let that be
known all right with that um do we have
a blue sheet for uh this and did we have
any
online activity for this uh yes it's
211 there were two people opposed two
support oh two people supporting one
opposed and one neutral for the online
testimony and then for the blue
sheet we have nothing on that so with
that I am going to close this hearing on
HB
and um we should break for lunch and be
back here at 1:00 for our subsequent
hearings thank you very much and sorry
we ran late today hey we only ran late
like by eight minutes that's not too
bad
um I wanted to uh ask the committee we
heard the bill uh uh 16 hb1
1626 this morning relative to the repeal
of certain designated funds and relative
to this aort to the apportionment of dog
license
fees is anybody opposed to us executing
this bill at this
time um it seems to me that with the
support of of Dr Crawford and uh the
commissioner
Jasper uh and also um the report put out
by Ways and Means give a compelling
reason for us to pass this bill and uh I
would like to PLL the committee and see
if it would be okay with you to execute
and I would say that I support uh I
would support that as well so okay
wonderful uh representative
smart hi the only thing that I I would
see I would I would support that Bell
the only thing that I question is the
wording Companion Animal just because we
have so many service animals and
companion
animals um that it
is it's it's just talking about people's
pets not companion animals so people
bring their dogs into the grocery store
because it's my companion animal and I
need it for emotional sec security or
whatever um well this is this is how
statute is already written okay we are
just changing the uh amounts
appropriation of funds okay so all right
representative NAB thank you I just
wanted to clar clarify that the question
New Hampshire Municipal Association
raised has been satisfied to their okay
thank you very much then I'm
support okay so with that um do I hear a
motion
representative Bixby I move a to pass
on HB
1626 representative kraton I second that
motion thank
you um is there any discussion on this
bill seeing none I would request the
clerk to call the role on uh executing
HB
1626 thank you madam chair uh this is an
aut to pass motion rep representative
kraton I representative ktoa yes
representative Arnold yes representative
Brad I represent
kulan represent Kenny yes represent
Penza yes representative
smart representative Bixby yes
representative sopitas
yes representative Duty yes represent
Murray yes represent Jam yes represent H
Haskins I represent Howard yes represent
NAB
yes
represent
bman bman bman sorry about that bman
bman yes and Madam chair
yes 180 motion passes do we want this on
consent no
objection thank you everyone we'll close
the exec session on hb1
1626 and I believe representative Bixby
you can do the committee report for this
I could do thank
you I don't think you have a
choice all right um I would like to open
the hearing for
ca14 relating to the environment and
natural resour sources providing that
the state shall maintain and improve a
clean and healthful environment and that
is being presented by representative
Horgan introduced rather so
representative
organ as you correctly noted Madam chair
I am represent Timothy Horgan and I
continue to represent straford County
District 10 which is the town of Durham
and um I guess you all have it in in
front of you CA S4 adds the follow would
add the following language or state
constitution if passed and I don't know
you know want to get in the whole rig of
role about how a constitutional
amendment is passed or it needs a uh
needs 240 votes in the house uh whatever
60% of the Senate is I guess that's 15
and then need two-thirds of the people
of the general election so it's um
anyway so it's uh so what it's it would
it would add article
83a which will be placed right after
article 8 83 which 83 is a rather long
article that's in a section entitled
part two form of government
encouragement of literature trades Etc
anyway so what it says is the people of
this state shall maintain and improve a
clean and healthful environment in New
Hampshire for present and future
Generations the legislature and
magistrates shall provide adequate
remedies for the protection of the
environmental life support system and
provide adequate remedies to prevent
unreasonable depletion and degradation
of natural resources and um this was uh
based on article 9 section one of the
Montana Constitution but with the style
rewarded the match the style of the New
Hampshire Constitution
um we here in New Hampshire we're very
proud of the fact we have one of the
oldest state constitutions um Montana
actually has one of the youngest ones it
was adopted in 1973 so it was written in
the early 1970s about the same time when
the Environmental Protection Agency was
founded and
um and the
and um so the reason and the um and
actually I was inspired to introduce
this after reading these new stories
about a landmark court case in Montana
which was Ricky held at all versus the
state of Montana at all and I actually
have a copy of it here I thought of pry
of copies for everyone but it's 103
pages long I mean it's makes fairly it's
actually makes fairly good reading but I
wasn't sure the one that dumped that
much paper on everyone but uh I I'll
give a copy to the clerk and I certainly
raise have copies printed up if people
want to look at it or you can look it up
for yourself so a diverse group of young
montanans sued their state government
for tailing failing to take adequate
action against global warming um they
were challenging the uh they're
challenging the constitutionality of the
state's environmental energy laws which
severely limited the state's ability to
mitigate the environmental damage caused
by fossil fuels you so Montana here like
New Hampshire the people are sometimes
pulled the resident State sometime
pulled in multiple directions on the one
hand you know it's it's a very beautiful
state with a small population like ours
also like a very large area like ours
but it also has a large fossil fuel
industry so you know and
um and so the uh the plist were uh
talking about how that had negatively
impacted their life so they had a very
they had uh young people aged from about
six to 21 from all walks of life one of
the um hell versus Montana PL actually
has a connection to Hampshire and
actually to my my community so woman
named Georgiana Fisher is now um 21 she
was I guess 17 when the law she was
first filed she happened to be a uh
Elite Nordic Skier and she's now a
scholar Athlete on unh's ski team and in
fact one of her uh one of her grievances
about the existing law was the fact that
uh her trainings become difficult
because the snow pack in
Montana um doesn't start forming now
until January it used to start forming
in November so that cuts the amount of
like live training Nordic CrossCountry
skiers can have on on trails and that's
actually um I don't cross country ski
anymore but certainly we all noticed
there wasn't any snow on the ground
until uh till till yesterday so which is
not how it used to be so um I know I
know this is a state 2,500 miles to so
to the west of New Hampshire but global
warming is a problem in all 50 states
and you know we we he we've had bills
here in New Hampshire that would uh try
to restore restrict our own State
government's ability to deal with the
consequences of global warming like we
often we' buil I've seen bills that go
both ways about for example since I live
in the sea Coast what to do about uh the
problem the problem of uh the problem of
uh you know rising sea levels
so and uh so anyway our New Hampshire
state
constitution doesn't have an explicit
protections for for the environment
although I mean it's it's it's implicit
um and in fact um we've generally done a
good job over the past 250 years of of
maintaining a clean and healthful
environment and uh environmental laws
are I think they're I think they're
pretty strong we did hear some
discussion earlier about how they could
be made stronger but they're you know we
we take the environment seriously but I
think this will uh help us make it
easier for us to take the environment
seriously by putting these explicit
Protections in the State Constitution
and so that's why I um that's why I hope
the committee will will uh recommend
this bill ought to pass and um hopefully
the hopefully down the road the uh the
Full House and the Senate and the people
of the State of New Hampshire will vote
by a sufficient super majority to pass
it so that's um that's it I do have a as
I said I do have a copy of the uh of the
court of the uh of the uh Court uh the
court order from from Montana it's in
the uh what they call the district court
for Lewis and Clark County which is the
county where the state capital of helon
is it's actually the court is actually
roughly equivalent to our Superior Court
but it's a it makes for interesting
reading but um anyway so thank you very
much Madam chair thank you to the
committee and if you have any questions
I can try to answer them thanks thank
you any questions from our
committee I do have a question thank um
the term clean and helpful environment
means a lot of things a lot of different
things to a lot lot of different people
well yeah that's fine so
um how would that be any kind
of um
definite
language to be added to the Constitution
well it's I mean it's very general
language we've added a general language
to the Constitution before it's
certainly more General than say the one
about the right to privacy which we
passed a couple of years ago so I mean I
think I think it's broad I mean my mind
it's clear so that's uh I guess that's
basically basically uh basically my
answer certainly I don't think anybody
wants a dirty or unhealthy environment
no yeah as as probably uh as we probably
saw from the debate this morning we had
for
example uh representative ger yeah thank
you madam chair and thank you
representative Horgan for taking my
question so my question has to do with
how you see what you see the effect of
this amendment being in Practical terms
and one of the things that comes to my
mind is a possibility I'm wondering uh
what what you think about this uh is for
example with the Department of
Environmental study uh Services pardon
me uh a lot of states have Departments
of Environmental Protection yeah uh who
have a mission that is explicitly to
protect the environment uh the words
protection and and prevent both appear
here in your Amendment so with an
amendment like this would one of the
effects be to D provide direction for
state agencies right so that this
becomes Central to their mission and
again I think about Environmental
Protection as opposed to Environmental
Services which is very often simply a
permitting agency yeah sure yes so I
think it would help clarify the mission
I mean they the dees doesn't have to
change its name if it doesn't want to
although we've changed some State
Department agencies since then but yes
that would I think help Focus their it
would help make their mission a little
bit more explicit it's a mission which
they've already I mean they I think they
already are committed to Environmental
Protection but this would uh just
clarify it and back them up I think so
thank you madam chair thank you sure
represent Bixby yeah um I'm a little bit
um concerned about the language uh shall
provide adequate remedies for the
protection of environmental life support
system and prod provide adequate
remedies for
uh to prevent unreasonable depletion of
and degradation of natural resources and
the um remedies implies that there is
already some sort of
damage and it is creating a baseline
assumpt it would be creating a baseline
assumption in the Constitution that
there's damage and I'm not sure that
that is really what we want to be doing
oh um well it's up you're um the
committee is the committee uh it's it's
your bill now you are free to amend it
and um I I uh I think you're I think
your your point your your point may be
well taken I mean certainly in fact
there already has been a lot of damage
to the environment so the you know
whether we want I mean regardless of
whether we have the presumption in there
the damage does exist so if if U I
basically basically took the existing
wording from from uh from this state
which is uh you know
been there for been there for 50 years
and worked pretty well there you know
there are uh there probably are other
ways you can word it if you want to so
it's up it's up to the committee to do
that so follow up sure follow so so the
the wording uh that wording and that in
that sentence is pretty much verbatim
from the Montana Constitution yeah
pretty much i i u i translated into the
uh I mean to the style of our
Constitution and Me Myself and the
drafters but uh we pretty much which
echoed that provision of the uh
Constitution they did put a lot more
environmental uh things into their
constitution probably just because they
were writing it in the early 1970s the
same era when the the EPA was introduced
when there's a lot of people viewed the
environmental Shields differently they
did in
1776 when or I guess it was 1783 but
when we
were drafting our constitution so okay
thank you but certainly free to
certainly fre re reord it so that's uh I
understand that's your right and
probably very well may improve the build
so I'll wait and see what what you come
up with so representative kraton has a
question thank you for presenting this
representative hgan I appreciate your
testimony the I'm just going to drill a
little bit down on represent on
representative bixby's question I what
is your understanding of the definition
of the word remedies does that that does
that mean that the state then pays for
anything that's perceived as an
environmental
degradation what how do you how do you
see that word what what does that
mean similar to what I believe we see
else in the Constitution about the
redress of grievances so see when
something's wrong it's the government's
job to fix it it doesn't mean they
necessarily have to pay for every Remedy
or do everything that people ask but
like we are
um both in the legislative branch and
the other two co-equal branches uh
required to look out for the interests
of the people and including the uh
including the people's interest in a uh
clean and healthful uh environment so
it's uh mean somewhat the same thing as
like uh you know the regress of
grievances that appears elsewhere in the
Constitution
so anyone represent ger thank you madam
chair thank you again uh representative
Oregan I just wanted to in connection
with points raised by Representatives B
being and Katon uh as you said you'd be
willing to entertain other possible ways
ofing this I was also confused about
there's a paradox I think in talking
about remedies and preventions in the
same Clause right remedies is to
literally to remediate something which
has already happened and to prevent
something is to prevent something so uh
in this case I also think it raises
issues around uh also as representative
kraton was saying are we talking about
remediation of something that is already
been done which is one thing or we
talking about taking active measures to
prevent something else from happening
and I actually think those are two
different functions and so maybe that's
something that's worthy of more
discussion I think you're connected in
so far as um when you're pre the purpose
of prevention is so that you then don't
have to have a remedy down you know down
the road so if we uh you know it's a lot
easier to stop the damage from happening
than to fix it after it happens so
that's that was my thinking but great
thank you okay oh um representative
Murray thank you um thank you madam
chair um thank you representative poran
um for taking my question I just wanted
to double check with you and maybe
perhaps uh just make sure the Secretary
of State's office um it looks like the
the question to be printed on the vot in
the voters guide it just says the
Constitution do we have any concern does
it need to enumerate state
constitution did you repeat the question
again sure I just wanted to make sure um
in in the the Bill's direction thank you
it's um it's section five yeah uh excuse
me section seven lines um
four5 and my question was it seems like
uh that section directs the Secretary of
State's office to print the voters guide
and it just said the Constitution I just
didn't know if um there was any concern
making sure that it was enumerating the
state constitution um May
I this is a I mean this is an issue with
all Constitutional Amendments that they
have this this little summary of it uh
in the voter's guide and people aren't
always satisfied with it I mean I think
that's I mean I think I uh I mean I
wasn't I wasn't dissatisfied with the
brief summary of and the voter's guy
will also include you know the exact
language of course which also appear in
full on the ballot I mean that's uh I
mean that is like an ongoing dispute
over how to present constitutional
amendments to the public at election
time so it's not just this is nothing
unique to that Amendment but um I think
that's come up in election law a number
of times so
I'm you can uh I mean certainly that too
like the amendment is like the Tex
Amendment itself is something that the
uh you know the committee it's in your
possession you have the right to to
reword it if you think that's not a good
good summary but that's that's that's
what the drafting attorneys came up with
and it looked it looked good to me so
that's that's why it's there I don't
representative BBY yeah so this is um
this bill is going to a second committee
bill
committee do you know if the second
committee is uh election law um
I tell you the truth I I don't know but
that's maybe I misre I thought this was
going is this a second committee uh let
me look and see there's so many it is
not an early b okay yeah it's not an
early that's what I thought cancel that
question yeah I know I mean I've done
I've been on Judiciary which is
considered considered a cacr that pasted
a couple of years go although I was
actually personally opposed to that one
so in that case um we were the only
Committee in the house and then we sent
it over to the over the Senate and you
know went through the and
also yes I don't think this is going to
a second committee I I'm not sure why it
was scheduled for the first day which
but that's my the first day is good as
any other day so here we
are any other questions for
representative Oregon oh I'm sorry
representative Penza
so in the state constitution I just
wanted to point out a couple things do
you feel that um under article one where
it says therefore all government of
right originates from the people is
founded in consent and instituted for
the general good don't you think that in
a sense uh covers a piece here of what
you're looking for you know maintain a
clean and healthful environment but in
some sense
all the entire all of our rights come
from you know are founded in consent
from the people so right there there's a
conflict of interest with your with your
Amendment because you're you're you're
basically telling people what they have
to do versus telling them what their
natural rights are so that's my first
question and then I have a second
one I mean that's that's probably true
of all the Articles you know the general
good is uh that's the overarching
principle and then we have uh you know
about over a hundred articles that uh
explicitly Define what the general good
is so I don't
think um I don't think that I don't
think this one um I don't think this one
complaces with so-called natural right
more than any other one does and of
course the word natural means like of
nature so this amendment is about trying
to protect the natural environment so in
that case um that's not quite the same
thing as a natural right so I don't see
a contradiction there but
um I guess we I guess we disagree on
that but you have a followup I do have a
followup so then of course under article
two you have enjoying and defending life
and Liberty acqu acquiring possessing
and protecting property and in word of
seeking and obtaining happiness instead
of having such a
long paragraph here why couldn't CU
you've got something here just clean
healthful environment why couldn't that
be in there as one you know one one of
the other comma in statements instead of
because then you get into the legislate
magistrat shall provide that's not
really how the Constitution works and if
you look at the last article here
um you know no law changing the charter
or form of government in a particular
city or town shall be enacted by the
legislature except to become effective
upon the approval of the voters of such
town so article 39 and article 38 and 39
also contradict this a little bit um I'm
not not sure just off the top of my head
I'm not sure if I agree with that
analysis I mean certainly if you want to
put it if you want to have a similar
language somewhere else in another part
of the Constitution that's that's fine
but this is a this seemed like they
seemed like an appropriate place to put
it and goes right after a very long
paragraph about uh what was it let me
get the exact thing form encouragement
of literature trades Etc so that that
seem like a place seemed to me like a
good place to put it um there are other
places you can put it so those um this
is just about article to um that's
certainly something the committee can
you can discuss amongst yourselves at
the work session so I this this is this
is a this is what I came up in
conjunction with the drafting attorneys
it's not the only way to address the
issue and of course uh it's already this
issue is already implicitly um it's
already it's already implicitly defined
elsewhere in the Constitution but I
think there's some value to explicitly
uh defined it and that's what I think
probably just about all the other 100
plus articles in Constitution are doing
to you they all sort of grow out of the
that first one so thanks representative
NAB thank you very much thank you for
speaking here today representative organ
um I take representative Pat's point
because I think the first sentence has
potential as a useful part of the
Constitution I think I have a real
concern about what the Baseline of our
environment is right now and how you
would Define that Baseline we all know
we don't live in a clean and healthy
environment you know all when all is
said and done um and where do you define
that right now I don't know what Montana
was like in the 1970s it probably also
had environmental problems but I feel
like 2023 New Hampshire we all know
there's many pollutants in the
environment and I don't know how you
think about what's happened already and
how you go forward so um I don't know if
you thought it I guess I'll make itan I
don't disagree with any point I've never
even uh never even been to Vermont I
mean I've two friends who uh I do
friends who grew up in bosma Montana the
same place where the woman is now the
uni ski team so I I mean I know it's uh
State that's uh you know it's a very
state with a very small population like
ours it's also one that's uh very proud
of its natural environment although it's
also uh torned in other directions
because has a large fossil fuel industry
in a large uh ranching industry but um
so they and um certainly in the lawsuit
they did you know the young people who
who sued the state they did talk a lot
about what makes uh Montana unique like
for example this woman georgana Fisher
I'm not speaking on her on her behalf um
but you know she was a uh she was a
skier and she grew up in an area that's
a bosan is a major major ski resort and
their economy has been uh you know
affected by you know the uh the lack of
snow in recent years the more
unpredictable unpredictable climate and
um all the other 15 uh 15 planers told
stories about similar aspects of their
experience so that's you know it's I'm
not really not really not really that
much of an expert on Montana but that's
uh but I'm probably on Solid Ground
making at least those General
comments representative daty uh yes
Madam chair I'd like a point of
clarification um if this bill is now
owned by our committee okay and we will
most likely have a work session on it
would
representative uh Horgan be available at
that work session to help us craft the
bill so that um you know I mean it seems
like we're trying to craft the bill here
and and if it is our bill and we will
have a work session I'm wondering if we
would just move on and have some of
these questions answered at that point
yes it's possible if we have a work
session that includes this bill I'm sure
representative Morgan would know about
it yes I'll do it do what I can I'm on
the Judiciary Committee which is like
yours is a very busy committee but I'll
I'll do I'll do whatever I can to be
helpful so and this is um you know this
this is not necessarily the only way to
address this issue so representative
Howard you had a question thank you
thank you madam chair um just to pile on
a little bit with the word SMI smithing
it seems like if we were to take out the
a few words it it would be more clear
and more concise I would suggest um
taking out clean and in the health and
just leave provide a healthful
environment and take out the I would add
natural in there healthful natural
environment and take out the two um
phrases of adequate remedies for and
just provide the protection of the
environment and and again again I don't
mean to inter interupt you but that's
the kind of uh comments we would deal
with in a work session
okay any other com uh questions for uh
representative Horgan on his
introduction of this
bill seeing none thank you thank you
very much I see there's a lot of
interest a lot of interest in this issue
more actually so more than I was
expecting so I hope uh hope hope you
have a good time working on it and I'll
do what I can to help you so thanks
thank you with that I'm going to close
the hearing on cacr
14 the next bill that we are scheduled
to hear this
afternoon is hb1
1630 I'm going to open up the uh hearing
for that bill uh hp1630 which is
relative to Extended producer
responsibility and I believe we have
representative parel here to introduce
his
pleas welcome to environment and
agriculture oh I'm sorry excuse me
before we move on um the for
um the previous
bill cacr 14 we had uh for the online 33
support we had 33 support foros four OPP
POS and there's no there was no blue
sheet
okay I'm sorry um go ahead
representative par I'll introduce your
bill and good afternoon good afternoon
again thank
you we have a bill before us that
addresses waste reduction at the source
this is state in rsas is preferable over
landfills or burning and before we
discuss those
it's good to have discussion of the
means available for for Source reduction
an epr is most promising of all these
strategies um there are some concerns I
understand that I have heard some
concerns such as
uh epr uh will pass uh cost onto the
consumer there's no evidence to back up
this and in fact quite the opposite
seems to be the case the little evidence
we have is from a Canadian study and if
there were cost differences between PR
nonpr provinces they were so slight as
to be immeasurable we had testimony from
Clark coron uh the program director for
collaborative Sol waste strategies and I
refer you to page 10 of the final report
which I hope you all had a chance review
I know it's a hefty report 200 odd pages
but uh I wish I had my copy here I tend
of walked off that this morning um but
it
does provide testimony over three days
of many different interested parties all
who spoke in favor of VPR business um
industry environmentalists all in favor
of it at least in principle at that time
we did not have a bill on which to base
any solid critiques we do have that now
and I'm here to keep this bill alive I
hope um now the consumer is already
paying for these tipping fees we either
be pay directly through our taxes or we
pay through tipping fees when we go to
the dump so we're already paying to
clean up well here's an example right
here I'm a musician a guitarist this is
what I needed in order to my guitar work
the guitar string I ordered it from
Amazon I hope I'm not plugging them
order it from a online company how's
that they sent me the package I will be
throwing that package away and they sent
it in an envelope which will also be
thrown away so in order to get this I
have to dispose of this and they did not
ask me if I wanted to uh have this extra
burden upon myself and upon my
municipality uh epr will lower the
playing field to make sure that the
people who want to sell things like this
will
be have to answer to those people who
are willing to sell it in a paper
envelope and the like
so that's another advantage of
VPR um let
see as I said before this is the only
Bill directly dealing with waste
reduction across the board I know there
are several concerns that will be
addressed by people will be testifying
after me um one is
uh that it relies heavily on Source
reduction I think that yes that is the
goal but if we have a Level Playing
Field and make sure that all the players
are involved to have a seat and a voice
at the table um including the consumer I
think we can mitigate any uh feeling of
I don't want to have to pay for this
program if we all can come together
another criticism I think and I'm not
sure if this is well founded is that it
relies heavily upon uh Department of
Environmental Services oversight we are
looking to have one hire the Department
of Environmental Services not several as
a financial report uh tends to indicate
one person to
oversee what we call a producer
responsibility organization a nonprofit
set up to Steward These funds and to
make sure the funds are levied
accordingly
um I think that's about all I really
have to say about it maybe I could also
add
uh well there was I know my report
talked about we live in a free market
Capital Society I'm not prepared really
to in involve myself in an intellectual
discussion of the this nature at this
point I don't think it' be good for us
but I will say that I was not elected by
free market capitalists I was elected by
constituents who uh wanted me to fairly
bring this matter forward to reduce
their the cost of their disposal cost
and I think this bill does that by thank
you representative parall um so I have a
question
that you chaired um a study committee on
extended producer responsibility correct
true okay
was this bill written by the committee
was this something that came out of the
committee I wish it were written by the
I was entire committee did have more
input we had one person was only able to
make half the meetings and um that makes
it
hard uh we had lots of testimony uh we
had things that we had model legislation
that we looked at from other states we
had a model that we looked at from a um
environmental organization
and uh all those
models discussed certain certain things
we do not discuss here in New Hampshire
such as they were focusing on such
things as um incineration and the like
this bill does not do that uh this bill
focuses on one thing and that's getting
a seat at the table for everybody who
has to deal with our waste situation
including the producers and the
consumers and and just as a followup so
so that study committee came out of HB
253 yes and there were specific um there
were
specific criteria that you were supposed
to study from that yes we were do you
have the items that you were uh charged
to um study with
that I I have them here and I can say
that um oh well thank
you
um we examine existing epr laws in other
States territories and international
jurisdictions which we did um and we
were uh looked at possible targets for
epr including packaging single-use
Plastics beverage containers electronic
waste batteries automotive waste and
hazardous waste we did that um ass how
these laws can be adop adapted to the
existing Solid Waste Recovery
infrastructure in New Hampshire I think
the bill speaks to that direction
um and uh solicit in Industry
stakeholder input on approaches that
manufacturers and Distributors would be
best able to undertake or facilitate we
did our best in order to do that um we
did have some we had the New Hampshire
beverage Association who I think they
are speaking later they have concerns
but prior to the legislation and I State
CS generally true they generally are in
favor of the idea of some form of
extended producer
responsibility um Stak um let's see
suggest possible legislation we did that
um and
uh yes that that we we did there was
five areas there and I think we
addressed all of
them okay thank you questions from the
committee representative ger thank you
madam chair thank you representative
partial I just want to to clarify to
follow up on the the chair's question
but this is not a a a committee Bill
correct so the bill doesn't have to
address all of those things that were
charged to the committee because it's
not a committee Bill am I am I wrong
about that uh it is not a committee Bill
uh we had three people at the end of the
uh um study uh um committee
um address the need for further
legislation uh Deborah El Schiller
Senator El Schiller uh made a motion to
draft further legislation was secreted
by uh uh representative Arnold Davis and
I was a third vote on that and we
Advanced the idea of passing of
submitting
legislation however with our and I I
know we're all familiar with how our
office of legislative servic was swamp
this year um I got the bill in we
drafted it and uh it was a real scramble
to look for sponsors so no it does not
the sponsors are not generally not
necessarily the ones who were on that
committee thank you I just wanted to
begin with to clarify in terms of why
this bill may not address all of the
items that the committee was charged
with is because this is not a committee
Bill uh which it makes sense I I ask a
second question you may thank you uh so
last night good time snowy uh evening I
read both the Chairman's uh report from
the study committee and The Minority
Report I also read the new B anual Solid
Waste report report so a good time was
had by all um and and looking at the the
banial solid waste report I see between
2023 in
2045 in 2023 we are 27% behind our
Target goal for for Waste reduction in
2045 we are going to be more than 50%
behind our Target goals for Waste
reduction packaging constitutes about a
quarter of what goes into our landfills
so is it conceivable that we can make
any significant progress toward those
waste reduction goals without seriously
addressing the problem of packaging
going into our
landfills I I believe that we cannot and
I would also add to that I think this is
a prime time for us to proceed with
setting resetting the table having both
consumers and producers sit down
together and decide what's in the best
interest of our long-term environment uh
I think we have a window of opportunity
here and by 2045 that window will no
longer be available to us
so again it comes back to I think while
this bill I'll fully admit I think they
probably will need some amending um but
I I'm more than happy to help with that
work and I do think that it's a bill
that I would hope makes it on the next
step I think we need to keep this
conversation going for Source reduction
I think there's a handout in fact going
around that um indicates the priority
that Department of Environmental
Services puts on Source reduction it's
our number one priority and I think up
till now we have not been addressing
that very effectively thank you thank
you madam chair representative Murray
thank you madam chair um and thank you
representative I empathize with your um
some somewhat frustrations on the
packaging um I recently was looking at
having some delivery of of some items to
my home and uh there there has been a
move by industry to provide
uh recapture return programs such as
Terra cycle and many other types of
things like that but one of the entities
that I was looking at had none none of
that available to them and said it in
fact it said this is not available in
your state um and it showed all of the
packaging that would have come with it
um that's the first time I've even uh
seen to that degree where it enumerates
what types of packaging may have been
included to that degree and that I had
no other options if I was choosing to
order it I would be stuck with what was
there there so I opted not to but in in
in in any case my um my question to you
would be you enumerate in the bill um
that the state com controller has
oversight over the program we have been
uh within this committee talking about
oversight around online sales and online
purchases for quite some time and I'm
curious to know who would be overseeing
that portion of what you're trying to
address such as what you're uh what
you've presented like as a physical
demonstration today
MH well we know what's being brought
into the state we have their sales
records um we also know that we can put
these hands into qualified producer
responsibility organizations nonprofits
that specialize in ascertaining the
impact of the of this various packaging
and able to assess what uh the
what how to modulate fees in order to
discourage over production of packaging
um and one of the Beauties I think of in
of extended producer responsibility is
that the producers go into it knowing
that they will be paying a fee knowing
that that fee will be they'll be able to
modulate that fee by the choices they
make this will not Outlaw plastic
packaging it will
hopefully provide a level playing feel
for them to consider alternatives look
if I go to and I was McDonald's a couple
years ago I was delighted to get my
burger in a cardboard box my fries came
in a a paper envelope and my drink was
in a waxed paper cup I thought that was
Splendid is it cost efficient can they
compete with a burger joint next door
who's selling it in a styrofoam
clamshell if I have stock in the company
I want that company to make the product
and deliver it as cheap as possible so I
get as much profit from it but if I have
stock in my community and in my
environment I want a Level Playing Field
and if we can somehow make that more of
a Level Playing Field companies will
want to sell the products that you want
in the packaging that you want that you
desire but we need to join with what
most of the world is doing and what
Canada has done what several states are
already either currently engaged in or
have legislation in front of them exent
producer responsibility is something
that's being taken up across our nation
and the world and I think that if we
don't on board with it we're going to
end up
being basically paying the cost of other
people's uh efforts in this
area sorry for a little longwinded
representative kraton has a question and
then representative Vick thank you
representative I know you put a lot of
hard work into this and the goals I
think are are admirable the the question
I have is in implementation and you were
just talking about
cost um and so the produc user going to
pay more for this end to endend
Viewpoint it's going to cost the the
manufacturer more to ship that product
out because he's paying for the end
endend environmental impact so how have
you figured out what that cost might be
to the consumer because at the end of
the day the consumer is going to one
that's going to absorb that cost and so
how do you look at at that um especially
in the environment we've been in where
Money's been tight across the board for
the last several years are we talking
about consumers how do we figure the
cost uh in proportion to what their
tipping fees and Municipal Taxes will be
which we're already paying for the the
product itself talk about if I go to buy
that hamburger and McDonald's is
responsible for end to end environment
how much how much more am I paying five
bucks for a whopper or am I paying 10
bucks for a wer oh I see okay yeah yeah
well well this these costs be passed on
to the consumer um the I will say
that there is no empirical evidence that
shows that happens and the only study we
actually have and I'll be frank with you
is a Canadian study that says that um
the cost is negligible uh and I I really
mean legible less than a penny on a
dollar for a um well even less than that
you mean uh Chuck hson the guy from um
who was part of the author was helped
author the uh or promote study um he was
quite adamant this saying it's so small
that it really is immeasurable um yeah I
would have the same concern I I can
understand your concern wow where
they're going to have to pay these uh
fees but these fees will be Pennies on
their sale that's a very small
percentage as far as we can tell
followup okay I I hear you but I'm
confused if you're if
you're adding an additional
requirement onto these businesses how
can it be
negligible what was the rationale on the
study that said that the cost increase
to the consumer was
negligible what was the uh impetus for
the study no no what why did they think
that was true that it seems
counterintuitive to
me oh that that if you put an additional
requirement on businesses yes that then
that creates a cost mhm that that
company would not pass that down to the
consumer and I don't understand how it's
a negligible cost well I I I I do
understand I mean your first your first
thought would be that you know wow if
it's going to cost more to make the
product because they have to pay for the
uh um producer fee then it's going to
cost more to the consumer but as I was
saying before
repeatedly um the only benefit the only
cost benefit we see to the consumer the
only one we're able to measure is the
one which has lowered their tipping fees
and lowered their Municipal tax cost
there's been no evidence that it has
actually raised the prices of products
and the and as I said the only place
where they actually did try to study
that was the Canadian provinces
comparing to different provinces and
they found uh again no evidence that
that actually occurs I you know I
understand your concern and I think this
is something we need to watch out for
which is why we need really good a
really good independent extended
producer responsibility Watchdog
organization which is Bill provides for
and it doesn't not do it through the
department of inter final Services I
should add um that's we're talking about
one position there not several um okay
thank so much representative Bixby you
had a question yeah so
um so how where are where are epr
programs already in place and um uh what
sort of track record do they
have they are in place in South America
Europe Asia Canada um most of the world
actually has gone this route Europe has
led the way in it they've been doing it
in in parts of Europe since
1992 um so we do have some bit of a
track record run on as far as what how
they manage it
um in the United States we have I last I
think was four states have enacted
legislation I think it's Oregon
California Colorado and Maine um and
Maine is worth mentioning because the
roll out on a program like this it's not
you pass the bill today and everything
becomes fine tomorrow this will require
um impact studies it's require quite a
bit of um leg work in order to get the
program up and running um and we don't I
don't think want to make the mistake
they made in Maine where they made
exceptions for the paper industry and it
really through their
whole it put everything else out of
balance the Plastics and other
Industries felt like they were being
unfairly singled out and we want a fair
Bell so I'm hoping that we can get that
um other states
uh yeah I I know that many other states
are considering it such as New York as
well I there's 17 States somebody else
I'm sure will have the information
unless I knew was like 17 States had EPA
epr legislation in front of them
representative kulon was you had a
followup yeah I had a follow I'm sorry
do a followup and then you're next so I
I guess the followup is are all of those
epr programs uh related to are those
just packaging programs or is that
covering the gamut of things like from
Electronics to paint to whatever uh I
think that yeah on a state state basis
they differ but primarily I think the
four states I mentioned are concerned
with packaging I should also add we have
EP we already have extended producer
responsibility here in in New Hampshire
we were one of the first states in the
nation to pass extended producer
responsibility for mercury um and we
have a model which is a small model but
nevertheless it's something we can build
on in order to expand that um it's
effective it
works representative kulan thank you
madam chair and thank you for taking my
question sir um I was wondering if you
have any concerns about epr policies
benefiting larger corporations over
small businesses like for instance
Budweiser might invite you know epr to
have an advantage over like a smaller uh
local Craft brewery for instance there
is a part of the bill that addresses
that very situation because I feel very
sensitive for our homegrown New
Hampshire businesses and I already feel
like we are often already at a B big
disadvantage uh there there is a carve
out so that uh they will be given time
additional time in order to incorporate
the policies they need to do in order to
uh comply with epr
legislation and uh I think that's
important to maintain and I thank you
for interested in that too it's a big
one may I ask where in the bill that
carve out is um I'd have to look for it
but uh if you want to give me I would
gladly do that or
um or I can get back to you later
whatever you prefer your preference you
can get back to me later okay
representative NAB you had a question
thank you very much Madam chair um I
just wanted to follow up on
representative kraton's question and
make sure I understand from a packaging
standpoint um does it also just include
mindfulness about how things are
packaged we all have the example of the
giant box that comes with one little
tiny thing in it or a company choosing
to use something that's recyclable
versus not or smaller packaging or you
know there's been this real push to over
Packaging things it feels like so is
that part of extended producer
responsibility or is it a real shift in
required
materials I think to some degree it will
be a shift but would not be a hard one I
think there are many people like myself
who are already out there looking for
environmental answers such as re
representative Murray mentioned earlier
um looking for these Solutions and I'm
delighted when I uh as I said go to
McDonald's and they give me my burger
and it's not in a styrofoam clamshell I
not a big fan of their but but you know
would make me want to go back there it
would make me want to support a business
that's that's looking sustainability for
the planet rather than raising my
disposal cost yeah and I think that
there is also Pro a provision for
educating the consumer in the bill a
small amount of epr funding can go to
that end and um I think that's also
going to be key in making this bill work
I should you know speaking of funding by
the way can I can I
add um it's I think it's very important
I think industry would agree with it
that any fees collected go directly to
managing the program I don't think
anybody wants to be in the position of
having this become a tax upon
industry um bless you maintaining a
program is one thing using the money to
uh benefit General funds I think we need
to be very careful about that which is
why we need an inspector General the
Department of Services thank you
uh I have I have a question and then you
um so I'm interested to know for the
study committee how many businesses came
and uh testified uh to your committee or
provided comments I should be able to
find that one a lot quicker if you can
just let me pull up my uh I do
everything with PDFs my apologies but I
tend to be a paperless
person um we
had and and if you look at the final
report it's I think it's on the in the
index
um which is on what
page well we can move along and
representative you can you can uh ask
your question I don't want to hold
things up thank you madam shair um
representative uh paral are you aware
that in I believe it was the Sunday
conquered monitor there was a big
article on Recycling and one of the
things that was interesting about that
was was some of the cost of the Tipping
fees um for example The Tipping fee for
Willer wheer has gone from $30 a ton to
$90 a ton and one of the things that um
the article indicated was that that town
municipalities were not able to really
control these costs because it was a
matter of function you know of supply
and demand uh but I noticed in your bill
um that it it appears that you have
incentives included in this so that
manufacturers can change their packaging
reduce the weight of their packaging and
therefore um their costs associated with
the program will go down um is is that
correct or am I reading something into
it yeah no that's correct there's a $5
term for that called Echo modulation
where they're rewarded they can reduce
their fees by selecting more
environmentally friendly packaging and
like I said before I think that many
companies would like to do that but they
look at the cost of it and they're um
concerned about that Level Playing Field
that we all want to participate on and
this and Echo modulation what that
actually does is level the playing field
field for them and makes it fair for all
parties concerned I'd like to think it
does that's that's the entire intent of
the bill right there in fact I'm
not representative Murray you have a
question yes thank you madam chair um
thank you uh representative parshall for
taking my question um my question is
around the fee structure which I am
assuming will be enumerated in rules um
and then to follow to follow up if I may
yep um I know noticed on page 17 line
three that it says that the new
subparagraph applications of receipts is
a dedicated fund am I also to assume
that that's a non-aps fund If This Were
to be stood up is this intended to be
stood up in
perpetuity um I believe that it does say
non-aps doesn't it I well I don't see
that in the bill perhaps it just says
dedicated fund on page 17 line three yes
so but it does not not say non-aps Okay
um this
yes I don't have a good answer for that
right now I'd have to go back and I look
further on deeper into the bill and um
that's all I can say okay thank you
representative
Penza so being new on the committee I
don't have a lot of history with you
know here everything that you have and
and have read through some of this but
not enough to digest it all I just
wanted this kind of goes back to um I've
been following this for a long time and
especially in regards with plastic
so this we're not looking at it from a
producer standpoint for incentives for
example like federal tax incentives for
someone that's going to be producing
something with corn and compostable what
those Dan plant-based bottles all of
that kind of kind of stuff so for
example if you're a business and you're
purchasing those like be good or there's
a place in Dober that has that they use
all their straws and all they're all
compostable that there's a tax incentive
for them doing that as well as we're
producing that stuff you know here in
our country um so we have less of that
waste like right from the source MH it
was uh asked by one Committee Member if
we could provide a tax incentive in New
Hampshire to do much of the same but the
problem is that we don't have that kind
of those kind of taxes in New Hampshire
I know and we'd have to incorporate
those kind of taxes if you want to give
an inside of and I think
that it's just I do do not want to bring
up the Spectre of taxes um I know that's
a very divisive issue um I I love the
federal tax incentives I think they they
work well but I don't think it's
something that we can apply here in New
Hampshire yeah because the big big
plastic produc and all of that they're
pennies you know how you were talking
about Pennies on the dollar right not
well Pennies on the dollar to them is
millions of millions of dollars so
they're never going to shift to that
kind of unless there's an incentive um
to do so and not just protecting our
environment is enough so but but the
whole idea of as I said before that big
$ five wor of echo modulation that
provides the incentive they're paying
into a fund that they can get a rebate
from
depending upon how they uh um choose to
Market to package their product and if
they choose that it's not only going to
help them to reduce their cost but it's
going to help on the other end with all
of these tipping fees that we're so
concerned about that are skyrocketing
right now and our landfill sighting and
all of our you know environmental
concerns with where we put all of this
rubbish as I said at the very beginning
this is one of the very few bills that I
know of right now before the house
that actually deals with Source
reduction making less garbage not how to
deal with the garbage we have but
actually making less and I think it
would benefit both consumers and
producers to have a seat at the table in
order to figure this one out thank you I
hope that answers your question no it's
great thank you any other questions from
the committee representative Bixby yeah
so uh you said that there was a
mechanism for um helping out uh local
businesses and I I'm wondering if it's
if you're referring to uh in um on page
five line 11 section Roman five a
producer is exempt from the requirements
and prohibitions of the
subdivision uh uh in a calendar year in
which the producer is realized less than
a million dollars in gross revenues
during the PRI prior calendar year or
the producer sold offers for sale or
distributed for sale products contained
protected deliver presented and
distributed in or using less than one
ton of packaging
material uh is that what you were
thinking of in terms of the protection
yes that is that is exactly the Clause I
was looking I thank you for finding that
I hope that helps mson of Coulson so
would reading that would it be
appropriate to think that someone who
was uh using the poultry the the
Thousand bird poultry exemption would
not come under the epr rules for their
um the plastic wraps or uh vacuum wraps
around their chickens because they just
wouldn't have they would neither meet
the income nor the packaging volume
requirements I think that I that that
being the point it helps to preserve
some of our smaller New Hampshire
businesses and uh gives some you know a
little little footing against larger uh
corporations thank you so to follow up
on that what is the rationale for those
particular
thresholds uh those thresholds were
recommended
um by I think was the
uh clf I believe recommended them I
can't say to that um but they were
recommended and they they seemed
reasonable to me and that's all I will
say I do think that as we go down and
study this problem situation I think
that there will be much to reconsider
Maine enacted their uh extended producer
responsibility three four years ago and
they still are tweaking it out and doing
lots of Ru making um so I guess what I
really answer that representative ER is
that it's a starting point I don't think
it's a would necessarily have to remain
a fixed point but it's a starting point
from which we can use in order to draw
rules
out so am I correct in saying that this
this is sort of a boiler plate pulled
off the shelf legislation model leg
legislation from somewhere oh or this
this is not tailored at all to I mean
with with regard to you saying it would
have to be tweaked um so this is not
really reflecting New Hampshire there is
a whole part of the bill also which I
decided to
incorporate I read several bills and I
you know I mean did I plagiarize other
bills uh by drafting this one um I
borrowed heavily I won't deny that
because they work effectively in other
places however there are places that I
expect people have questions on and I
think that they're probably going to be
good questions I have a whole list of
toxins uh deeper on in the bill that I
think
that I would expect industry to at least
take a good hard look at I would expect
them to do that I included them uh under
recommendation um I'm willing to
negotiate and the inclusion of them upon
recommendation but it does the bill does
have those Provisions in there so that
we don't end up uh three years from now
saying oh yeah we finally got a good
bill except it doesn't do anything for
our small New Hampshire businesses we
left them out I did not want to do that
so I no I don't think it's boiler plate
I think it's what I was able to borrow
from different legislation in order to
uh come up with a bill that I think
would maybe not work off the shelf in
New Hampshire but would be a positive
step in the direction of something that
will effectively reduce our tipping cost
so this
is um so yeah no I so I guess I would
say I don't really see it as a boiler
plate so I I would
say thank you any other questions
representative
Penza so following up that same section
on page five line uh I think it's line
four or section four it basically says
that the producer shall annually submit
to both the department and the packing
reduction organization a written
declaration signed by the chief
executive off officer verifying the
producer's compliance with and then it
gives you know the rsas
so in a sense there's not really going
to be anybody overseeing or policing
that that's really going to be on you
know they're going to be on their honor
in doing it
correct we we will have in place the
bill provides for a producer
responsibity organization which will
shepher their their numbers they give
and you know how much verification
they'll be able to do
um I suppose if we need to go back and
verify we could also find access through
online sales and the like too I don't
think it'd be a total you know trusting
the producer okay but I think there's a
place where we we began there can I have
a followup sure um so there's like four
different businesses that you know we've
been frequently um you know one a couple
of food service places one's a kind of
an organic uh type store um that where
you can eat at as well and they've been
doing this for years now I have to say
that they're if you went and probably
got similar food at another place you
could
save three four dollars on each meal
just because they are I mean the ones
that I'm talking about you you do you're
spending a lot more but they're I mean
all of their stuff is like I said
compostable um made with the corn prop
all of that it's it's wonderful so um
these folks depending on if they qualify
would be able to have this type of
incentive the ones that have been doing
doing it for several years now in the
state most definitely
yes uh they would not be penalized
they've been doing it for several years
do you think that it would trickle down
to us and maybe we could have less we
could spend less money on the food well
I hope as it trickles down to us and we
have less uh you know Municipal tipping
cost and lowers our taxes that's that's
that's a big one for the right
there yeah the food the C thank
representative
Bixby so in terms of the
the way that the program is
overseen uh tell me if I'm getting this
right so there's a um P which is a u
packaging reduction organization they
are sometimes called that as well yes
and that is that would be a private
sector organization that the state would
hire yes we would contract with them
and then and so so de Dees would be in
charge of doing the hiring for that and
then
uh there and you would also have a
Inspector General within Dees that would
sort of overse the pro yes okay so so
that so we have the pro that is
basically uh getting lining up all the
companies that have things sold in
packaging in um in New Hampshire and the
prro would get paid by those packagers
and overseen by those packagers and then
the money from that would go to a
combination of municipalities and Dees
and the cost of running the
pr and then uh so the so if the pr so um
how does how does the bit with the
municipalities getting money work and
what what does the what do they get
money for doing
that how what does that money go towards
in the municipality
um well the main purpose of it is
to
reduce the actual bulk of what's being
brought into the state and the
municipality will benefit from having
that Source reduction their tipping fees
will be reduced because of that Source
now M will also be able to I think well
at least as far as education goes which
was something which one of the committee
members wanted to see more education
funding they they'll be able to ask for
Educational Funding around these areas
in order to further the goals of their
um recycling whatever follow up followup
go ahead so uh so would that money to
the municipalities also go towards
helping recycle a larger range of
packaging that they might that might
still be coming in maybe smaller volume
but larger range like more than just one
and two
I I I can't say for certain that is what
the their they would choose to do with
any municipality but I I think that the
industries would like to have more
access to these materials and they make
it easier for them to recycle so I think
that at least in theory industry would
be behind having accessibility to those
materials and so yes I I answer thank
you representative
kto thank you madam chair and thank you
thank you for taking my
question um I'm listening to the
testimony here today and we're talking a
lot about tipping
fees and how that is great for
municipalities and for taxpayers because
we'd be reducing tipping fees um through
this program is that correct that's
correct
yes
so the question becomes if we're
reducing tipping
fees
um would how would these places that are
accepting the trash stay in business if
they're not getting the same amount of
money and I'm just playing you know
devil's advocate here but they're also a
business and how would this affect
them I think there'll be somebody
speaking after me that can say a lot
more about the impact of um our current
waste flow has on our municipalities um
I believe there's somebody who will be
testifying later um but I will say that
considering our current landfill
situations and what's leeching into our
environment in an uncontrolled nature
um I don't lie awake at
night worried about trying to keep the
uh our landfills full in New Hampshire I
think that problem pretty much takes
care of
itself representative Murray thank you
madam chair um and thank you for taking
my question one of the things I keep
thinking about is um um the difference
between recapturing and recycling
products um and I do think that based on
I think to um the question that
representative Bixby made um when we
talked about expanding Plastics other
than one and twos or commodity based
prices based on you know those available
recycled materials I'm curious to know
um whether or not you've made a clear
delineation between recapturing programs
versus recycling programs because they
are because they are different yes I can
understand that and then this bill I
I'll be very Frank with you it probably
does not address that as fully as
perhaps it could um which again you know
if I could have put a bookmark in there
for that the way that we had bookmarks
for education and for uh small
businesses you know it would be it would
give us something to work with and I
think that's an important point and I
think that it's worth discussing as part
of this legislation or any other future
legislation yes representative germ I
had a question yes thank you very much
uh Madam chair and I just want to follow
up on representative K's question uh
which I think is an important question
for us to focus on because the number
one goal in our waste managed strategy
is reduction right so uh wouldn't the
same thing apply to any plan that leads
to the reduction of how much we landfill
uh we are supposed to be moving
progressively toward putting Less in
landfills which will drop tipping fees
uh so while I understand where the
representative is is coming from isn't
the actual point of our Solid Waste
Management plan precisely to do
that yes I I
I yes yes yes thank
you any other questions for
representative
parshall oh representative
Bixby so you have a a definition of
toxic material materials and I'm I'm
having trouble locating exactly where
you have it in the in the bill but I was
wondering if that toxic materials
definition was uh something that you
came up with on your own or whether you
received that from another
organization uh there
were at least two other bills I looked
at that had something of this nature in
it and I thought it was important at
this time to include that so uh yes from
other bills yes so I I guess part of my
concern is that the some of the things
that are used to characterize a toxic
material are um are really fairly broad
uh and uh one of the so
um part of the issue with something
being toxic is how much so if we have
one part per billion of pasas that's a a
fair amount of pasas if we have one part
of billion per billion of table salt
that's not so much but if you don't
include the quantity that makes
something toxic if you have if you put
um 100 pounds of table salt in your well
your well is now toxic so I'm I'm I'm
worried about the definition of toxic
not being
sufficiently uh um precise to make it
clear what actually counts as toxic and
what doesn't for the purposes of
packaging yes I and and again I will say
that I see some of these areas as
negotiable okay and I think that's
important to I
mean I would have liked I'll be frank I
would like this have been a committee uh
legislation was asked earlier on if
that's was represent myself or the
committee
um we had an opportunity to study this
in depth and uh now granted we did have
a very short amount of time to do it in
and I I and that's the nature sometimes
of New Hampshire politics
but but I do feel that collaboration is
important on a bill like this and we
need to have as many different
viewpoints as possible and as many much
critique as possible on it I'm hoping
going forward uh any concerns like this
can be part of an amendment that will
further the bill rather than uh
dismissing the bill is because it does
not parse to certain levels so just to
be clear I am incredibly impressed with
the amount you've managed to pull
together that most of which is really
quite solid and uh it would be really
kind of unbelievable to do something
this long and complex with no flaws
whatsoever so I'd like to congratulate
you on on this on your initial start
with this I I suspect we'll probably
need to spend a certain amount of time
working on amendments and I hope that
you'll uh help us with that process I
would very much relish that opportunity
and I want to thank you for your kind
words any other
questions thank you representative paral
for introducing your bill and fielding
all these questions oh that's my
pleasure I'd like to call next um to
testify um
director whimet from New Hampshire
Dees who's been sitting waiting
patiently uh good afternoon Madam chair
and members of the committee introduce
uh your companion to introduce your
companion as well I'm both myself and my
absolutely thank you mam chair uh for
the record my name is Mike whimet I
serve as director of the uh Waste
Management division for the New
Hampshire Department of Environmental
Services and with me I'm joined uh today
by Michael norc who heads up our
materials management and planning
section um we're happy to be here before
you to talk about House Bill
1630 um
I I want to start by saying that the
concept of uh extended producer
responsibility is something that's been
talked about in many sectors not just
for packaging but for other other
materials um and it's a it's a concept
that the department is receptive to We
believe that um Extended producer
responsibility can be very effective and
as the sponsor representative parall
indicated um actually New Hampshire was
something of a Pioneer in that with
respect to Mercury many many many years
ago and that that program um with with a
lot of participation by many of the New
England states the northeastern states
and then eventually across the country
um has become very popular and very uh
uh successful to the point where a
number of states are you know kind of
ramping their their efforts down because
they they feel like the the products
they were trying to address have been
addressed so I again I want to open with
that because I think that's something
it's important for for this committee to
understand that that approach is
something that the department is very
receptive to and supportive of um having
said that um we do have some concerns
about House Bill 1630 obviously has been
a rather uh a lengthy you know
discussion with the sponsor about
questions about how this would work um
the primary concern that the department
has though I think is really a very
practical one and that is that we it is
an FN Bill we were asked to do a fiscal
impact worksheet and we did that and uh
when we looked at all the various
requirements and and and tried to kind
of school ourselves on how the bill
would work uh we concluded that it may
take as many as eight positions for us
to implement this program which is we
don't I I don't say that very often
that's a it's a pretty big number and uh
of course the bill does not make
appropriation for any of those positions
so really based on that alone um the
department is not in a position to
support this bill uh because we we
believe that um you know there would
need to be provision for that and
Appropriations made and um it's not
clear to us that
that that this partic well I guess I'll
start I'll continue by saying that
um we believe epr as I said is very is
an is an approach that can work but we
believe it really needs to involve some
kind of critical mass of states that are
working that are looking at similar if
not identical legislation to set up um
uh Frameworks and implementers that can
do it on a at least a regional if not a
national basis so that it is both easy
and understandable for the industry to
implement and easy and understandable
and coste effective for the states to
implement and so for that those reasons
we think that this isn't quite ripe yet
we're certainly it sounds like there's a
lot of interest and a lot of you know
acknowledgement on the part of the
sponsor that this may need some this
bill may need some work and Dees is more
than happy to participate in discussions
about how the bill could be amended to
to make it more achievable but at this
point my understanding is we have about
three states in the union that have
passed laws with respect to epr um I
think perhaps the one that is most
closely aligned with this bill would be
what Maine has done although it's by no
means the same um and they've been at it
for a few years now and they're still
working on rules so these and we don't I
I will I don't want to T I'm not spoken
directly with my counterparts in Maine
about this yet and I certainly will do
that but my understanding is that there
they're struggling a bit in getting this
launched and uh what we'd like to do is
make sure that if we were to go into
something like this as a state we really
understood how it would work and and we
we want to be successful we'd want to
meet the deadlines in the in the bill
and make sure we set up a program that
was effective and cost effective for the
state I have a question and so I know
that you are a participating member of
the solid waste working
group to what extent has the solid waste
working group um discussed epr and epr
legislation um and have they do they
have any thoughts on on how this would
be implemented in New Hampshire the the
group has certainly talked about epr as
a concept and in in in wide ranging
discussions as we were working on our
Solid Waste Management plan it was
recognized that epr can play a
meaningful role in reaching the goals of
our plan which include waste reduction
and Disposal reduction um so so in the
general sense I think the group is
certainly um on board with that concept
I don't know that they've talked I don't
believe they've talked about this
specific Bill thank you representative
kraton and then
you thank you Mr whimet for your your
input it brings something that it hadn't
occur to me and so as you read the
bill if I'm Manufacturing
something in Massachusetts for example
and selling it in New Hampshire how do
I how does this Bill affect my
business well and I I will be honest I
I'm not sure I fully understand how this
bill I'm sure I don't fully understand I
don't really understand maybe even some
of the fundamental ways that this bill
would work it's a little bit confusing
to me but I my understanding would be
anybody no matter where they are that
markets products that are P are
contained in packaging in the state
would be potentially um subject to
assessment of a fee for the with somehow
appropriately prated to the amount and
the type of material that they are
selling in New Hampshire and that this
producer responsibility organization
would be responsible ultimately for um
assessing that fee and collecting that
fee and then as time went on and it
matured a bit a couple year years and uh
municipalities would be in a position to
be reimbursed for some of their costs
for recycling from a fund that would be
set up to to to for those fees to be
collected as well as the cost that de
that New Hampshire the state incurred to
administer the program one of the
concerns we have is that we think that
the collection of those fees would not
happen for some time and the state would
be required to but the state has a lot
of work to do to get to that point so
that we would be having to hire the
staff and and do the work and incur the
costs of the uh initial uh uh study
that's required as well so that there
would be no money in the system other
than State money until that happened and
then not really entirely clear to us how
much money would be collected or how
that would how that would work okay
thank you representative Murray thank
you madam chair and uh thank you
director uh for taking my question so as
aside from the um PR that would be stood
up potentially are you aware of in these
other three states are there any other
public private Partnerships that states
are dealing with to deal to help address
uh maybe some of your concerns about the
eight additional staff members that you
would
have we'd certainly look into that I I
my and again not a student of what
exactly is happening in these other
states my understanding are my belief is
that Maine has engaged a pro or the
equivalent of a pro under their law but
I don't know how far along they are
beyond
that representative NAB thank you madam
chair thank you director for taking my
question um do you have any sense of how
a regional approach would even work or
if there's precedent for that with
environmental issues because we hear a
lot about we're New Hampshire and we
don't care what this other state is
doing so I mean is there not for I hope
oh no not from you at all um is there a
a real path for that to happen I I I
think there is yes um and the first one
is the one that I mentioned uh in my in
my testimony and that is the the um
Mercury reduction or IMC the
international Mercury and reduction
Clearing House I can't remember what the
E stands for but um it is a program that
um is actually administered by the
Northeast Waste Management officials
Association of which New Hampshire is a
member that's a eight member uh
organization of the northeastern states
um and they Waste Management officials
and and I've been involved in it ever
since I became director and the agency
actually is a founding member of the
organization it was it was created back
in
1986 their real purpose is to help the
states collaborate on waste management
issues and in fact one of the early
things that they did was to work on imar
which is this Clearing House and and
basically States got together and said
we we've got a real problem with
contamination and we need to do
something about it we need to get it out
of products and um we want to do it in a
way that is is that's manageable that we
can all effectively do um that makes it
easy for industry to comply with it
because that's that's when compliance
happens is when you make it easy to
comply so they created this um imur
which is basically a clearing house
that's run by neoa and it collects all
the information there's a lot of
reporting requirements associated with
manufacturers of products that have
mercury added to it and I it started
with some of the obvious things like you
know blood pressure cuffs and
thermometers I but it really branched
out to a lot of other products where we
knew we had Mercury fluorescent bulbs
Etc and the idea was that there would be
a requirement for those manufacturers to
report on the contenter Mercury and as
these things were either phased out or
banned that mercury was Bann in certain
products there'd be a a requirement for
those organizations for those
manufacturers to report that they were
compliant or if they weren't to report
when they would become compliant and uh
the states that worked together at New
Hampshire was a leader in that and
actually it was sort of stood up and uh
uh a lot of staff there there was at
least one staff member in Dees who was
active on imer group with num MOA for
for many many years and continues to
this day and that worked really
effectively because it what it meant was
there was this um database and and folks
managing a regional system or what
really became a national system system
um at very little cost to the individual
states but together their resources
really help solve this problem and so I
think that's the example that that I'm
thinking of I mean that's a little
different because we're we're not
necessarily just talking about reporting
here we've got the fee structure and all
that so there's a little more going on
um there are more recently there are um
uh there's a similar organization uh
called um the intern Interstate
Chemicals Clearing House or ic2 that is
also administered through neoa
it has pretty National reach not every
state is a member and in fact New
Hampshire's not a member yet because we
don't have a program that it administers
so there's no point in but we're certain
I I hear about it every time I meet with
neoa the neoa board and it's something
we're looking at with regard to other
other possible initiatives but they um
administer something called the HP CDs
or the high priority chemicals database
in that system there's a number of
states that do have laws about um the
presence of toxics particularly in in
children's products that sort of thing
so they identify they collect a lot of
general information about a list of high
priority chemicals chemicals of concern
and then they actually do have modules
for states that have laws on the books
about toxic materials in children's
products or in other products um they
will basically it still cost money they
they'll pay to develop a state module
that will sort of be a a collection
point for all the
manufacturers who are subject to it to
go to One-Stop shopping they go to ic2
they make their reporting they provide
their information and um and so as a
result again it's easy for the
manufacturers because they go to one
place to provide the information and
then the individual states spend far
less money than they would if they had
to stand that program and framework all
up on their own so that's a long answer
to say yes to your question
representative Gera thank you madam
chair uh first of all I have to Marvel
at your ability to hold acronyms in your
head you must dream and acronyms which I
don't envy um so I'm going to ask you a
a different slightly different iteration
of a question I asked representative
partial based upon the most recent Solid
Waste uh management report uh so given
the projected shortfall uh compared to
our reduction goals over the next 20
years or so number one uh and number two
given the fact that our recycling rates
remain largely unchanged from the 2018
to 2020 period so given those two kind
of data points how feasible is it for us
to make a serious movement toward
achieving those waste reduction goals
without seriously packaging p uh
tackling the issue of
packaging I think packaging is
absolutely has to be part of the
equation it's it represents a
substantial portion of the waist stream
so we absolutely need to make progress
on reducing packaging in order to meet
any of our waste reduction goals
thank
you represent Bixby yeah so um I'm
wondering if uh you think that uh this
is in a some somewhat more abstract
level is the model of having uh
p uh oversee the uh interface between
the
manufacturers and the uh and the state
um in terms of the packaging waste
reduction is that a an appropriate model
and is it just a question of how we get
there I I I think I'm not sure about all
the very specifics of this model but the
the general model of having an external
organization handle the information
collect the information calculate fees
on a regional or national basis assess
and collect those and then interact with
the states I yes absolutely think that
can work I I do think that there's this
and it's frustrating I know but it's
some of there is a it's going to be
necessary to have a certain critical
mass of states that are looking to
implement a similar or identical program
in order to make it cost effective and
and actually make it work without it
being a really big lift for individual
states represent Biby followup so
uh let let's say I I know this is not
your preference but let's say that we
decide that we do want to go forward
with this uh you had eight uh you you
calculated that you'd need eight new uh
positions in order to to run this would
you need those all at the outset or
would is that something or would those
positions become necessary uh as the
program got further developed because we
know it's not going to happen instantly
no matter what we do I think some of
them may be phased in but the the
implementation schedule for the bill is
really only two years long we we're if
it passes in 20 um or I should have few
years it it basically becomes effective
I think in 26 or no excuse me in 24 and
then by uh 28 so four years later
everything's supposed to be set up in
municipality should be getting
reimbursements so um in that four-year
period you know we have in the very
first year if it passes if it becomes
effective September 24 one year later in
September 25 we're to have
administrative rules adopted which means
we would need to begin working on those
rules
even if we could figure out what they
should say right away in order to get
them adopted within a year so you're
going to need staff to do that we're
going have to we're also in order to
inform that rul making we'd really
probably need to do the study that's
required to be done every five years so
we'd have to have somebody to uh put
together a um an RFP for that study do a
selection and then work with the
selected contractor to get the study
completed there's a lot of work here to
be done and and there's a number of
components to this that are really new
to us I I'm not saying hasn't never
happened before but I'm not I don't
think I've ever testified on a bill that
required us to stand up in office of
Inspector General in the department so
um and then have a regular annual audit
beyond our normal auditing procedures so
there's a lot of components to this and
that's what drove up that number of
positions that we're just not accustomed
to seeing that in a bill of this nature
thank
you uh representative kulan thank you
madam chair and thank you uh Mr whimet
for taking my question
so do we know if Maine or Oregon or any
of these other states are actually
collecting data or providing evidence to
show proof of concept before we go and
spend over a million dollars by next
year
potentially I I really don't know much
about where I don't Mike if you have any
more information about where those
states are I I know very little about
where they are in their process um based
on my understanding all states in the US
that have a law on the books haven't
actually implemented them as of yet
they're kind of in the preliminary
stages like Maine is still developing
rules Colorado I think has just selected
a pro but hasn't actually implemented
the program California I think is still
working on implementation as well so
it's it's going to be rolling out uh in
the in the next coming years but it's
it's not there yet and so we don't
necessarily at least from where I sit
and what I've been kind of tracking uh
haven't seen any actual implementation
of yet follow up sure so we have yet to
see proof of concept that e actually
works in the United
States I I think there may well be other
examples of epr working but in this in
this packaging realm I'm not I'm not
sure we have um evidence of that in in
the United States
yet any other questions from the
committee seeing none I want to thank
you so much for your time and coming to
testify by and lend us your insights on
this important bill you're welcome thank
you madam
chair I'd like to Now call up um Tom
Irwin the conservation law Foundation
who's requested three minutes to
speak m members of committee please put
on your
um microphone thank thank you madam
chair thank you members of the committee
uh for the record my name is Tom Irwin I
direct the New Hampshire office of
conservation law Foundation uh clf
strongly supports this legislation um
and I I'll be brief in my comments and
uh to avoid
repeating much of what's been said and
and I do have written comments that I'll
I'll leave with the committee but um
point I'd like to emphasize is uh that
in the late n in the late
1990s the legislature
adopted uh the statutory policy that's
been referenced which favors Source
reduction as the number one way of
managing solid waste it ranks recycling
as number two composting as number three
landfilling as the least
favorable uh roughly 25 years later we
have made little to no progress on
Source reduction and are not recycling
nearly enough and continue to rely on
landfilling and Disposal as the primary
means and as you all know are seeing uh
a lot of that landfill capacity uh being
filled by outof state waste so to to be
successful on this issue the state needs
tools tools and epr
is absolutely a critical tool for
reducing waste at the source and
avoiding the need for Unnecessary
landfill capacity unnecessary other
disposal capacity that harms communities
and and the health of the people who
live in New Hampshire so we strongly
support this bill um because it takes on
Source reduction in a very important way
um there's been discussion of this but
you know there is a cost associated with
packaging waste someone bears that cost
and right now it's primarily
municipalities that bear that cost this
model shifts the costs to those who are
producing the packaging and it and it
does so with a model that will
incentivize those produc producers to
reduce waste and to reduce the toxicity
of that waste um so I think that's
really a critical element of this
model I I would agree with director whim
that that in a perfect world we should
be able to wait for this to be addressed
on the national level or even the
regional level um however we don't live
in a perfect
world I I I think it's fair to say this
will not be Ted tackled on the national
scale
and I I don't think we can afford to
wait for this to happen on the regional
scale uh we state of Maine has stepped
out is
leading while we wait for the rest of
the region to address this
issue the rest of the region is sending
their waste to New
Hampshire so New Hampshire needs to step
up and lead on this issue if we we are
going to work our way out of the cycle
we're in right now which is
unfortunately to have become The Dumping
Ground for much of the region with 50%
of our landfill capacity now going to
outof State waste so this is a real
solution uh we strongly support it and
we hope you we hope the committee will
as
well representative Murray thank you
madam chair um and thank you Mr for
taking my question um it was mentioned
and I know you've probably poured over
the the legislation too um some
incentivizing of Industries to move away
from uh copious amounts of packaging and
things like that um what I have seen a
few models within the state that are
starting to emerge around zero waste or
uh bulk stores that you can go and
refill things independently and I am
encouraged to see that um additionally I
I I did have the conversation I think
with the prime sponsor asking about
recapturing um which we know exists with
things like um plastic grocery store
bags which it's not enough um that's
just one form of packaging but um what
what other programs do you think we can
stand up within uh within that vein to
also address the recapture side of
recycling meaning with this model with
these funds what other types of
recycling programs could be stood up um
well I think to representative bixby's
point I think uh the the model would
generate revenues that would allow for
um recycling infrastructure and and
programs that uh could address perhaps
uh recyclables that really aren't being
accommodated as well right now um but I
um I will tell you I'm pinch hit I'm
pinch hitting today
um our lead Advocate on this issue is
out of the country um so I I don't
have I don't have concrete ideas as
to other types of recycling programs we
might see um but clearly it it would
create the path for more Recycling and
just as importantly if not more
importantly create the path for Source
reduction
representative Bixby so um I asked a
similar question to director rimsad I'm
I'm one just in terms of ways of getting
to epr for packaging do you see the uh
the model of a private sector um
packaging reduction organization uh as a
uh is that is that the ideal model for
um for trying to do this sort of
epr
uh representative Bixby I I don't know I
would defer to representative parall and
the committee that has spent a lot of
time to on this personally because I
have not um and as I mentioned our lead
Advocate on this who who has spent quite
a bit of time on this uh I'm sure she
would have an opinion but I I don't know
what the other models are uh but I I
commend representative parall for the
thoughtful approach that he's taken in
developing this legislation and it uh it
it certainly seems like a model that
that should
work thank you so I have a question for
you
um representative kraton mentioned
earlier uh had a question posed a
question to representative Parell
about uh increased costs that may come
to the consumer and as a result of
implementation of this kind of program
because we all know that businesses
whatever costs are borne by them um
ultimately show up in the price of their
product if the price of products rise
and you know there was a statement by
representative parall saying that those
uh PR price price in um inflation May
be very
negligible but still prices would go up
if there were costs that would be borne
by the consumer and I'm concerned about
how that might affect lower income
people
specifically um I'd like to get what
your thoughts are on
that thank you representative Madam
chair um I think uh as as representative
parall paral mentioned you know we're we
we too are aware of a Canadian study
which indicated negligible impact
um I think there is the the cost
savings aspect of this in that uh on the
backside in terms of disposal consumers
will not be paying um in terms of at the
point of
purchase uh that at that transaction
level um yeah as mentioned in Canada the
where epr has been implemented uh the
finding was the impacts were negligible
and I'll just circle back to what I
referenced uh what I mentioned earlier
which is the incentive based
model the the the the Bill calls for
Dees to engage in rul making to
establish the fee structure a fee
structure that
incentivizes less packaging and less
toxic packaging can also result in a
cost savings
for the The Producers meaning the the
packaging they ultimately produce uh May
cost less than what they are producing
before the
program representative ger thank you
madam chair and I I wanted to to follow
up on that because there was this
question about if it was a negligible a
cost that gets handed off to the
consumer I don't know how like how in
the weeds you are in that Canadian study
the the the letter that weed from Nora
your colleague Nora Bosworth says that
there is no
correlation between cost and epr uh
policies in those provinces uh so again
I don't know if you could speak to that
more in terms of what the study actually
says how familiar you are familiar you
are with the study but the committee did
receive that letter from Nora Bosworth
and the language that's used in that
letter is that the study concluded that
there was no correlation between epr
policies and increased cost for
consumers I I have no further
information representative gerana to to
share with the committee about that
study um but um you know we would
certainly be happy to follow up um when
my colleague is available and she's the
one who has spent time drilling down
into these issues representative Howard
you had a question um I it it seems like
it must be key to um have reduced
packaging for the key for the success of
this program to have the package be
reduced would there be an accompanying
trigger of Technology um to go with
that to you know to sort of to react to
the the differences in packaging
and thank you representative I I I think
it's it's fair to say that this very
well could trigger new technologies uh
we're seeing techn you know we're seeing
new business businesses now I I believe
there's one in Maine that is developing
fiber B fiber-based packaging as a
replacement for plastic packaging uh so
yes I I I would think this very well
could serve as a
trigger okay any other questions from
the committee representative Murray um
thank you madam chair um would it be
fair to say that um the word cost is
also could be C like uh categorized as
being an environmental cost as well as a
a fiscal
cost yes thank you for that question
representative Murray I I I think when
we talk about
costs
uh we really should be viewing costs
more expansively there are health health
related costs healthcare related costs
their impacts on property values um all
associated with the disposal industry um
the fact that you know we have trucks
bringing waste uh from out of state and
and traveling across the state to
certain
communities um to dispose of waste there
are costs that come with that and so I
think if if you look at the if you
consider costs more
expansively then uh it's all the more
reason why we should be focused on and
be providing uh the tools for Source
reduction so that we can break that
cycle and and move away from where we
are now which is primarily disposing of
our
waste any other
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony this afternoon thank you I'd
like to Now call Representative Jake
brillard to
testify
thank you madam chair and fellow
committee members uh I want to first
start off by saying I agree with the
overall premise of the bill to uh reduce
um Source waste and to lessen the burden
uh the financial burden that
municipalities face I don't think anyone
uh there's anyone that wouldn't agree
with that uh so I was part of this uh
study committee that was charged with
the responsibility of looking at
extended producer
responsibility uh myself as well as uh
representative Davis uh and we were both
on the minority side of uh having
legislation put through uh regarding
extended producer responsibility I just
wanted to briefly go over uh my Minority
Report if you allow which I believe the
committee uh members uh do have copies
of right well we want to make sure that
we um that you are addressing the bill
itself um and what your objections are
to specific parts of this bill um we
have the study committee report and I do
hope that members of the committee have
read it or plan to read it because um
there are some very Salient points that
are made uh so if you could keep your
comments to this particular piece of
legislation and perhaps parts of it that
you feel maybe are not workable or uh
any other objections to the bill but
please speak to the bill and not
necessarily rehash what you went over
during your study
committee so as as it was admitted here
in
testimony we have little evidence one
study outof country study Canadian study
that suggested there would be no C added
cost to the
consumer we don't even know if it works
in other
states to suggest that a
four 4 Day
committee study period would be
sufficient to have this bill go through
I believe is is
ludicrous uh and to suggest that no
negative economic impact to the state
would
happen uh but we need to rush
legislation through because the time the
clock's ticking we don't have enough
time um we could potentially P be
passing a bad Bill through to achieve
said goals when there are other meth
methods uh that can go about about the
same way um it was brought up that
education awareness program be
implemented to let the consumer know
that hey there may be there are other
choices that would put a less of a
economic uh environmental impact uh was
regarding packaging that you can
purchase instead of buying a plastic mil
C and you can buy a cardboard one
instead of buying a plastic egg carton
you can buy the cardboard uh one or you
know raise chickens on yourself instead
of buying you know bulk water
bottles um in bulk you could use a
reusable water
jug you know using recyclable plastic
bags when you do your shopping there are
other methods uh to go about uh as far
as in order to achieve the same goals
another method was to uh utilize the
recycling bill that was passed
SB let's
see uh that was passed into
law is that s SP 367 yes SB 367 which
utilizes the new plastic recycling tech
technology having businesses take
advantage of that to again reduce the
toxic uh impact in the environment and
to again overall uh lessen the the
amount that's going in there uh as
well no no
actual because this this does relate to
the bill I have to bring it up no actual
State statutes were analyzed in our
study committee to to justify this bill
we didn't we didn't look at Main statute
number dot dot dot here's the statute we
didn't look at California law dot dot
dot here's a statute we didn't we we
didn't even delve into those programs to
see how it how it could relate to the
state and it'll be beneficial for us uh
most of the stakeholder analysis that we
got
was on the last day of the committee
hearings where from concerned uh
citizens regarding the environmental
impacts of landfills versus um one of
the main objectives was the municipality
costs uh again there there are other
methods to to go about achieving the
same goals whether you look at out of
state trash you look at other
Technologies waste of energy other
disposal Technologies education
uh I believe we can achieve the same
goals that's desired may I ask um I
don't mean to interrupt but were were
there any people from uh companies that
create packaging or companies that um
use packaging
or did anybody who who who might have
come to your uh study committee to talk
about how they deal with their packaging
the main one uh I believe the the only
one was the American Beverage
Association um that they were
sympathetic to the overall premise
um of the bill but they were uh
is they weren't exactly
uh uh agreed they weren't exactly in
agreement about the uh methodology uh to
go about the uh reaching that achieving
that those
goals um I think in in our study
committee uh representative uh or
Senator I should say Ad Schiller agreed
with the overall uh premise that the
that the uh cost would be passed on to
the consumer that the manufacturer
producer would not eat the cost the fee
wholeheartedly out of the just the good
nature of their their heart um we talked
about leveling the playing field I I
believe the playing field will certainly
be
leveled when the mom and pop the more
independent
businesses will be taking on these
fees and not being able to do so because
they don't produce in Mass quantity like
some of these other bigger
corporations uh and so I believe that
will certainly level the playing field
uh and make you make things
maybe harder harder for them to
uh to
produce questions from representative
Murray thank you madam chair um thank
you representative for taking my
question um I guess um with regard to
the bill um we had talked about the
ability to level the playing field by
creating some offsets for smaller
companies and a carve outs um I think
that were enumerated in the earlier uh
representative earlier in the bill
um page five yes thank you thank you I
page five um section V yeah V uh lines
13 through 17 in the bill and I just was
curious to know whether or not um you
felt that those were sufficient
representative or if you had other ideas
and how um those offsets might impact
help help smaller
businesses
the the study
committee we did not have nearly
sufficient amount of time to review the
bill uh in the study committee a lot of
it seemed like the typ typical model
legislation uh that it may have been
drafted outside of the um outside of the
state and not related to um something
that a state
legislator or a multiple state
legislators would come up
with uh what what section exactly were
you looking yes yes thank Madam chair
may I yes sure it's page five lines uh
11 to
17 and that's really the area of
question that I was having uh sort of
question about help to smaller in uh
businesses within the
state
yeah
next it it may or may not help depending
on what type of producer you are
depending on what type of business you
have
um I think a lot of companies they're
already going to a
uh more environmentally friendly
packaging they're using less materials
in their packaging because it's it's one
is cheaper they're already using a lot
of recycled
Plastics uh and so the echo
modulation I don't I don't believe that
would be beneficial when a lot of
companies are already uh going that
route okay representative German you had
a question and then I'll get down to you
yes thank you very much Madam chair so
with the discussion about which I am
entirely in favor of trying to do a
better job of kind of educating
consumers educating the public at large
to make better better choices um I I
hear that and often those educational
programs lack the resources they need I
think to be as effective as they could
be but when again looking at our our
bial Solid Waste report uh that that we
just was published at the end of last
year we've seen that even with all of
the education around recycling maybe
it's not as good as it could be but
there's a lot of Education around
recycling we have seen no appreciable
increase in our recycling rate in this
state it's between 20 and 25% and it has
been for more than five years that
doesn't seem to me to suggest that a
when we're looking at the shortfall in
terms of our waste reduction plan that
doesn't suggest to me that an education
a public education policy is going to
make any
meaningful uh difference in people's
consumption uh habits so what I'm
wondering is and this is a genuine
question it's not meant as a gy question
or anything like that like based on that
what evidence do you have that suggests
even the most robust education campaign
is going to have a significant effect on
consumer Behavior again I don't I don't
believe it's the sole tactic I mean I
don't I I haven't seen enough awareness
in my town uh Nottingham uh I believe
there are other tactics involved to
achieve this the same goals again
looking at the recycling law that was um
from house uh Senate Bill
367 I believe it was uh to um you know
reap the benefits of that recycling
technology have businesses coming in and
and and reap those benefits uh again we
can we can look at out ofate waste and
see if there's any ways or by means of
diverting some of that waste having it
go to uh waste to energy trying to limit
limit that I don't think we've we've
really looked at that aspect enough
where
we and I think a lot of um a lot of
state legislators would say they would
agree that we have a significant amount
of waste coming into the state
uh you we would have to find some way uh
around the Commerce Clause because you
do have to allow for a free flow of uh
commerce between
states so but again the overall idea
that we need to rush something through
uh where we don't know if it's going to
be beneficial for our state is I just
can't see
um me me me supporting something like
this representative NAB and then thank
you madam chair thank you representative
for testifying today um you mentioned
the amount of time your committee had a
few times but I wonder do you think if
you had had more time you would have
gotten to a better bill or do you not
believe in epr in
general
I think I think both uh is true I think
you would need a
significant uh amount of
time to study this
when as as director whimet had mentioned
that you know laws was passed a few I
think a few years ago in Maine and
they're still trying to come up with
rules and
so is this a year-long
study
uh committee uh issue or is multi-year I
I can't I can't give you that answer I
just know having a 4-day committee
meeting to to study this and looking
this was not nearly enough time um
representative Marie you had a
question did thank you did your did you
have any data given to you or presented
to you that might indicate that we have
a larger infrastructure maybe that we're
not tapping into around um I I keep
going back to the concept of recapturing
things like disposable razors for
example I know that you know people who
shave there there are prepaid envelopes
that can get mailed back to the producer
so that those are not getting disposed
of I know that there are businesses
around the state that uh receive uh
double A and AAA batteries so that
they're not going into landfills and
getting tossed um so I'm curious to know
if if there was any any more information
presented to you about those recovery
and recapture side of things as well I
didn't see any I I mean I don't recall
uh seeing any data uh to that effect um
again I know there are other avenues we
towns most towns or nearby towns have
their household hazardous Way St where
they can save up their batteries they
can save up their bulbs uh other
potentially toxic material that they
could um you know deliver on said
days represent
Bixby so um just just so you can uh find
the reference I'm going to be making in
a in as I get towards the core of my
question um on page
14 uh section uh starting at line um
line seven so uh I was uh intimately
involved with the passage of H SB 367 a
couple years ago and one of the things
that so one of the questions I asked the
industry was what's your incentive for
making
uh plastic out of recycled plastic that
you needs to go through pyrolysis which
is a very expensive process as opposed
to making it out of Virgin plastic and
what they said was that in some
jurisdictions they are required to
include a certain amount of postc
consumer uh pla recycled plastic and for
uh plastic that is in contact with food
mechan iCal recycling is not sufficient
that it needs to be chemically recycled
and so uh do you think that uh the
section in this bill that provides for a
uh for a a minimum amounts of uh
recycled plastic in containers would
provide a good incentive for advanced
recycling see I I don't even know if
that's that's sensible Sensible because
you have certain plastic contain uh
containers that need to be rigid that
need to protect whatever product is in
said packaging you need to have certain
plastic packaging to prevent
cross-contamination
so using less and less uh is not
always efficient because you need it's
it depends on what product is being
placed in that
packaging I think I I think I might not
have been entirely clear okay uh
so uh the the rec the the plastic that
comes out of recycl advanced recycling
is essentially just like virgin plastic
it's made from the same chemical
components as are extracted from
petroleum or distilled petroleum and and
so uh what it doesn't have is the
contain minants that might be in other
recycled plastic so that's what makes it
food safe and in terms of the rigidity
well they it's basically like virgin
plastic except it's coming from the more
expensive Advanced recycling process so
their incentive was that jurisdictions
were
requiring uh a certain percentage of
recycled plastic in the food safe
packaging and the only way they could
meet that was by using Advanced
Recycling and I'm wondering if you think
that what is in this bill would be an
appropriate incentive for uh people who
are trying to sell uh plastic containers
in New Hampshire with food in them to uh
you know to to make those package to
make that packages using recycled
Advanced recycled
plastic I think it depends on the
I'm not a a advanced recycler um so I
can't tell you more about the the type
of product uh I just know that there are
benefits in in using uh said product uh
packaging um okay but I can't I can't
really delve into the specifics of
it okay representative comat
you thank you madam chair and thank you
representative bruland for taking my
questions
I hear what you're saying about this
bill and I do have my own concerns but
what I am seeing nationally and globally
is already a reduction in packaging for
instance I don't know if you know this
but McDonald's by
2025 will be 100% recyclable that is
their goal unor lever by 20 2025 they
will have reduced the amount of their
virgin plastic by more than a 100,000
tons I think right now the industry is
already speaking and doing it on their
own and if that is the case what is
necessary in this bill in your opinion
and what is
not well and just to
um just to re reiterate that I was I
think I was looking at these solid waste
report and I think we had less waste per
tonnage in 2022 versus prior years with
with a an increased
population and so as you said we're
already we're already having uh
instances where organizations are
looking to cut back um the amount of
packaging um the amount of waste that's
being inhibited uh
uh being provided to the uh landfill and
to the
environment
uh I mean I I don't know how much more I
could say on on this bill but that that
again I think the overall premise of the
bill is I I agree with the overall
premise the methodology again I I do not
agree with
when
a more study time is needed
B we need to see what our neighboring
states uh the the final result of what
our neor neighboring states have
implemented and
then how that how their their program
has help
municipalities we have a question from
representative kraton and then
representative
kulan and thank you for your your
testimony and your patience uh I I think
I've heard ch two separate things I
wonder if you could clarify the bill
that we're considering right now that is
not a result of the study committee it's
a separate bill I believe this bill was
was drafted and and given to us late in
the in the study committee though this
but it's not the study committee Bill no
correct correct yes yep all right thank
you representative kulon thank you madam
chair and thank you representative Brew
yard for taking my question um
so I mean with respect to my colleagues
and believe it or not I am actually
concerned about single use Plastics and
things like this but I'm also really
sensitive about the subject of Taxation
and when I read this bill I can't help
but think this is a really complicated
tax on consumers in a time of pretty
high inflationary rates I mean can you
convince me otherwise of that or what's
your position on that
I think you have to look at the
cumulative um aspect of it where we we
have high gas prices we have a higher
cost of living uh
inflation uh and now with this uh a
potential added
tax I think it takes it takes a toll if
you look at it in entirety um in it's
definitely just another added uh cost
that the consumer will eventually have
to deal with
any other questions from the
committee thank you for your testimony
representative brard we appreciate your
time and moving right along our next um
pink card is from Christina
dubben um sorry I didn't mean to
mispronounce your
name
okay
um thank you madam chair and members of
the committee I'm G to completely go off
script here so hopefully I don't go
doesn't go too badly but I just want to
show you because of all the questions
coming up what is actually going to be
incentivized what are producers going to
be incentivized to do with their
packaging when such a law is passed
things like this right we have fiber
based exterior packaging this is how it
came it was not in seven bubble wrap
envelopes like we see these days from a
certain large company um and then you
know here again more fiber based kind of
cushioning this is a fully recyclable
aluminum bottle that can be refilled so
it can be shipped back and refilled or
it can be recycled in your curbside
recycling bin recycled aluminum is great
um something else that you may
see getting the water out of products
when you remove the liquid suddenly I
don't need a giant red orange plastic
container sitting on top of my laundry
um washer right I can you know have
something like this um much easier much
lighter to
ship um you know and then I'll give give
you one more example this is a glass
bottle with a a metal top you pour this
into a larger glass bottle you fill it
with water at home and now you you get
to your cleaning so these are just some
examples of what we'll see more of and
some things not packaged at all for
instance like soap that you you know
don't need the
packaging deposit uh container container
deposit systems uh DRS otherwise known
as bottle bills kind of a dirty word
nowadays um that's the oldest one of the
oldest forms and proven forms of
extended producer responsibility bit of
a different system but it is a form of
extended producer responsibility so we
do have proven models in the United
States in addition to the four laws that
have passed that you've heard about um
one really important part of an epr for
packaging law or bill is the needs
assessment you can look at Maryland who
just passed um they were looking at an
epr for packaging bill they decided to
pass the needs assessment portion um so
that they could really look at how many
staff do they actually need to add what
does their waste stream really you know
look like what are the what are the
needs right so that's a really really
important part of um this legislation in
terms of
recycling so there's these Ecom
modulated fees producers are
incentivized to make better material
choices this is going to clean up our
streams right that yields better bail
prices when you don't have all this
contamination plastic all these
multi-layered Packaging those are not
recyclable mailback programs like
terracycle there's you know you can go
ahead and Google it they're being found
to be false Solutions these items are
not actually getting recycled less than
6% of all Plastics are recycled less
than
6% recycling is awesome for aluminum and
for glass and for paper and cardboard it
is not a good solution for Plastics
which
40 so 30% of the waist stream is
packaging 40% of packaging is single-use
plastic so that is a major um thing here
also recycled plastic has been found to
be more toxic than virgin plastic when
you recycle plastic uh mechanically you
have to add virgin plastic you have the
chemicals that came already in there
right to give it its rigidity and its
color and other properties now now
you're going to add more chemicals to do
what you want with the new application
plastic can only be recycled a few times
mechanically because it loses its
Integrity so again there vast
limitations um check out the consumer
reports issue from last week about food
packaging Bates bisphenols in all sorts
of foods packaged foods and fast foods
um that I'm sure in all of our homes so
I I'll leave that there it's a major
public health issue we're talking about
costs Health costs
um in terms of we are seeing
corporations standing up and making
these pledges we want to hold producers
accountable in statute because we see
these voluntary pledges again and again
they are not met so they come out with
them and then 10 year you know however
many years down the road oh well we
tried and you know we got we got this
far so I will say be careful about that
but yes the you know reduction is the
key word here um and that's what this
this policy seeks to do I will also note
that um hb1 1630 serves all eight goals
of the 2022 New Hampshire Solid Waste
Management plan um by obviously reducing
the quantity of the solid waste getting
the toxicity out of the waste stream um
you know ensuring adequate capacity for
the management of New Hampshire
generated waste right 50% nearly of our
waste is coming from out of state this
addresses that
frankly um so I I did not fully identify
myself I realized I just sat down hat at
it so I am um uh my I have many
different roles today I'm here um as the
volunteer campaigns coordinator for the
surf riter Foundation New Hampshire
chapter um and we do strongly support
this bill uh for all the reasons that I
mentioned um I think I'm gonna stop
there I will say one more thing there is
a bill in play right now in New York
Senator Pete harkam um an assembly
member Deborah Glick um it's moved along
pretty far um so I would take a look at
that as in addition to the needs
assessment uh process in Maryland and
I'll leave it at that thank you for your
testimony and I thank you for the uh
visual aids too because um I know
personally when I am getting items in
the mail I have seen definitely you know
not seeing as much bubble wrap anymore
I'm seeing a lot more paper wrap I'm
seeing a lot more more um paper instead
of
plastics so and to representative ktoa
point before we see a lot more of these
companies moving to these
items which begs the question why then
would we have to do something
statutorily to deal with that I mean I
remember I'm old enough to remember that
um you know when things used to come in
paper all the time mhm and then
everybody wanted to save the trees so
what we ended up with was now Plastics
and plastic packaging and that became
sort of the
standard and now I see this shift going
back to simple simpler
uh uh
resources so again as we're seeing
especially some of these bigger
companies moving to paper based Goods uh
packaging and so forth um I I do wonder
if there is really any need to uh russan
epr um procedure
through um I don't know if I'd use the
word rush I think that there's avenues
that you can take to make sure that you
end up with a piece of legislation that
you are happy with um again I will say
that the needs assessment is extremely
important and that is an option um you
can always move forward and needs you
know you can again you can tweak the
legislation to make sure that you have
that process first to um you know build
that that timeline in it is necessary um
because like I said you you are seeing
this but you are not it's not the
majority um of how I mean these
companies are really
standouts um and you know plastic is
cheap because the costs are not
internalized right um plastic is
produced in Louisiana and Texas and and
in Appalachia now um it's produced in
low income and communities of color so
production we don't see we don't think
about Upstream right um so it's really
not a cheap material and we're going to
see we're going to see those effects
increasingly on our beaches on our
streets you know microplastics I'm sure
you're all reading about all the studies
that keep cropping up about where they
are in our bodies um in the water you
know they attract all of the chemical
basically and become these little like I
don't know what you call them little
ships of chemical bombs um so I would
say we do have to have it in statute um
we have to create a leing Level Playing
Field and have everybody participating
in this and seeing reduction across the
board again you know with new New
Hampshire being somewhat unique and that
in that we have such a high percentage
of out ofate waste coming
in this
really starts to address that so that's
what I would I would say thank you
representative Bixby so um one of the um
elements in the bill is this is on page
14 line three um in case of a producer
that enters the market with 50% or more
by weight of its packaging being
reusable and contained within a reuse
and refill system that producer May
apply to the department for a waiver
from the packaging reduction
requirements so that that sounds like
there is some kind of credit being given
for people who are doing it right
although that doesn't actually cover the
entire range of people who are doing it
right uh so uh do you think that that um
that there should be a little bit more
uh uh extensive reward for people who
are doing things correctly because we
don't want the PE we don't company want
companies taking on the expense of doing
it right and then getting undercut in
the marketplace because they're taking
on the they're taking on the external
alties and not making the external
anymore that's where the Ecom modulated
fees comes in to place right so so
depending on the M there the fees are
set by U material choice and correct me
if I'm wrong but that's I think Dees is
part of that during rule Mak I'd have to
revisit the particulars about that um so
that's where a company could still
choose another
material in and they they're going to
pay more for it for the for the less
desirable materials for so for the more
you know toxic plastic they're going to
pay more money right um whereas this the
person who's doing the right thing is
going to pay less right so that's how
it's going to financially incentivize
them to do that and someone had asked
about Technologies you know I do want to
caution against um compostables or
bioplastics they can still contain
fossil fuel-based plastic it can still
contain peass and other chemicals that
traditional Plastics do they can um and
in that way mimic plastic in the marine
environment um or in the environment in
general so um but there are fiber you
know certain Fiers certain materials and
um melum so like mushroom based um
materials that are being developed so
there are um some really Innovative cool
things happening um and this will just
encourage more of
that thank
you representative H Haskins thank you
madam chair thank you for taking my
question these products are um in the
minority of companies that are making
them would you agree with me that the
reason why they're making them is
because customers want
them and
so it follows in that logic that we want
to give our
state the right
um laws to
incentivize more of this because people
can't do it on their own so I applaud
you for the information that you've
shared with us and I hope that we can do
better for New Hampshire thank you thank
you anyone else have a
question no seeing none thank you so
much for your testimony this afternoon
thank
you I would like to Now call in
pod I'm sorry I don't know if I've
pronounced it
properly and could you please spell your
last name for the
clerk uh good afternoon my name is an
podl it's spelled p o d l i p is in
Peter N Y thank you you're welcome uh
good afternoon and thank you for the
opportunity to speak uh my name is Anne
pod lipney and I'm in favor of the
bill um I've been awaiting this occasion
armed with scientific studies confirming
the toxic effects of plastic packaging
that uh leech into air Soil and Water as
well as the impact it has on our Public
Health my colleagues and many others
warn of the dangers of Plastic Products
including packaging consisting of almost
14,000 chemical additives most of which
have not yet been studied and hardly
regulated industry has announced it will
triple plastic production by
2050 at 3:30 a.m. my alarm went off
unexpectedly I thought instantly that
the Universe was sending a message wake
up the time is now to mitigate an Ever
growing waste stream onethird of which
is packaging that ends up buried burned
or borne out to sea often including
pasas otherwise known as forever
chemicals the alarm Bell is still
ringing we have examples of epr for
packaging bills successfully passed in
10 states and data to show that they are
economically and environmentally
viable our federal government recently
introduced the break free from plastic
pollution act that currently has 12
Senate and 45 house
co-sponsors it states in
part that humans ingest over 800
microplastics per day microplastics have
been found in human blood lungs and
breast mil
40 450 million tons of plastic is
produced each year a number that's
projected to Triple by 2050 in the US
the rate of plastic waste recycling
decreased in 2021 to between 4 and
6% it is estimated that there are
171 followed by 12 zeros I can't
pronounce the the number pieces of
plastic in the ocean and that 1,300
marine species have consumed Plastics
and finally Studies have projected that
the Plastics industry will emit more
greenhouse gas emissions than coal
plants in the US by
2030 its major solution in this bill is
very similar to what hb1 1609 is
proposing number one it's requiring big
corporations to take POS uh
responsibility for their pollution by
creating an extended producer
responsibility policy it's a policy
highlighting The Producers
responsibility for the postc consumer
management of its products and packaging
this includes number one shifting
financial and management responsibility
with government and key stakeholder
oversight away from the public and
Upstream to the producer and number two
providing incentives to produc producers
to incorporate environmental
considerations into the design of their
products and
packaging in addition it's requiring big
corporations to take responsibility for
pollution and establishes aggressive
sorts reduction targets for single-use
Plastic Products and beverage
containers here in New Hampshire we can
respond proactively and with foresight
and political will to reduce and
regulate plastic production excuse me
plastic packaging waste alarm Bells
including my own have sounded remember
the YouTube video of the helpless turtle
in excruciating pain with a plastic
straw lodged in its nose researchers who
rescued it painstakingly extricated the
straw to facilitate its breathing
thankfully the turtle survived our own
Survival
depends on the choices we make to avert
Waste Management crisis an epr for
packaging at both state and federal
levels has already proven a positive
solution as all turtles know slow but
steady wins the race hb1 1630 will bring
us to the starting line thank
you any
questions seeing none thank you so much
for your testimony this afternoon you're
welcome
and our next call Christine
vber Welcome to our
committee thank you madam chair and
honorable members members of the
committee my name is Christine babber
from Dover New Hampshire and I am very
pleased that our state is actively
considering an extended producer
responsibility bill that would provide
incentives to manufacturers to develop
products and packaging that will reduce
the costs of managing Solid Waste for
New Hampshire residents and municip
alities and reduce the waste stream and
toxics going into our landfills this
bill responds directly I think you've
you've heard people which is really
great referring back to the uh 2022 New
Hampshire Solid Waste Management plan um
it but this bill responds directly to
goal one of that plan um the goal of
reducing Solid Waste through Source
reduction I think Source reduction is
the important piece to keep in mind here
um and also goal two of reducing
toxicity of the solid waste
stream our state's Readiness to proceed
with such a bill should also be
bolstered by the grant funded New
Hampshire waste characterization study
that uh Dees is overseeing and I don't
know if
that contract has actually been awarded
yet but um it was in process the last
time that I checked an e epr bill for
New Hampshire would have multiple
benefits um and I'm going to refer to
some Research In My Testimony I'll be
leaving a written copy with links to
that research and some of what I'll I'll
be addressing are things that um have
already been raised as
questions so according to a recent
report by the recycling partnership that
looked at the impact of epr programs in
seven jurisdictions worldwide the rest
of the world is ahead of us in this
regard um and in six US states
implementing epr programs found that it
could increase overall recycling rates
by as much as
48% um that was from this particular
study but I have also seen other studies
that suggest it's been raised by as much
as
75% so education is a big piece of this
Ecom modulation another big piece of
this um it also creates nearly Universal
recycling access if you talk to people
around the state you will find everybody
doesn't have good access to recycling
right now um even in Dover where I come
from there are people who live in
apartment buildings who say you know we
C we we don't have recycling in our
building what can we do about this um it
also creates thousands of jobs um
hopefully eight of them would not be at
Dees I haven't figured out quite why
that would be required but anyway um it
would also boost the amount of recycled
content by millions of tons
um and reduce hundreds of thousands of
metric tons of climate damaging
emissions in epr states there there's
been a good bit of discussion today
about cost for taxpayers and
municipalities epr will reduce costs for
taxpayers and
municipalities the product stewardship
Institute claims that under our current
recycling systems consumers pay three
times we pay first for the packaging of
the product we've we've heard different
people mention the layers upon layers of
packaging um a second time for the
collection of the waste material and a
third time for the indirect costs
associated
with postc consumer packaging such as
increased health insurance premiums
resulting from higher illness and
disability caused by pollution caused by
toxics in that pollution um there's been
some discussion today about well isn't
this going to raise the cost of
products a there um actually have been a
couple of studies done on this a
2022 analysis from from Colombia
University estimated that the impact of
epr on customer costs would be about
a
69%
increase okay so less than 1%
increase a study Comm uh commissioned by
the Oregon departmentment of
Environmental Quality compar paed prices
of common consumer
products in epr and
nonpr jurisdictions in Canada we heard
this mentioned earlier it was a very
elegant study in that they actually went
and selected products in the different
provinces and compared the costs in
provinces with epr and those
without the study found again as been
mentioned no correlation between the
existence of epr mandates and consumer
product
prices the conservation law Foundation
asserts also that there's no credible
data indicating that epr would raise
consumer prices
um they estimated that adopting epr
policy would save Main's Municipal
taxpayers at least 16 million a year and
we have heard that their process um is
still underway but I would say that it
could be reasonably expected that
similar savings would occur in New
Hampshire
uh another uh interesting piece I think
when we're we're thinking about adopting
bills such as this is that there is
extensive support among voters for
adopting policies such as epr a
2023 Nationwide poll of us voters found
overwhelming support from both
Republicans
75% and Democrats
86% for Shifting the cost and this was
in regard to plastic pollution for
Shifting the cost of cleaning up plastic
pollution from taxpayers to the
companies that make and use the excess
plastic 66% of Democrats in a higher
number 70% % of Republicans say that
taxpayers should not have to pay for the
cleanup of plastic ways created by
companies so it is not surprising that
82% of Democrats and 70% of Republicans
agree that companies should stop
producing and using so many single use
Plastics and we could I think extend
that thinking to some of the other
products covered by
epr House Bill 1630 would provide strong
effective policy the bill opportun
offers opportunities to reduce waste
going into our burgeoning landfills to
reduce the economic costs of dealing
with difficult to recycle plastic and
other ways
to reduce a broad range of toxic
chemicals that are
carcinogenic
mutagenic meaning that they U cause
mutations in
human endocrine
disrupting it also um this bill would
Increase jobs it would educate
businesses and residents
about responsible reduction Reuse
Recycling or disposal of discarded
packaging and I think particularly
important it would help protect the
health of our environment and
residents I hope that you will seize
this opportunity to benefit New
Hampshire and its residents and vote
ought to pass on House Bill
1630 um I would also like to say that I
think that I attended pretty much all of
the committee meetings on this bill on
uh
epr and considering the short amount of
time I was
impressed with the work
that representative parall did about how
he tried to engage everyone including
those of us from the public um they
listening in um to help make this a good
bill um from just an Outsiders
perspective I think a piece of the
problem was that a lot of the some of
the committee members were not
there so um I I think if
you look at this bill how complex it is
how much is there I would hope that
representative partiall gets credit for
how hard he has worked on this thank
you any questions from the
committee no seeing none thank you so
much we have one more pink
card and and uh May yep oh There She
Goes we have testimony being distributed
thank
you excuse me now I'd like to call uh
Bonnie Christie to uh testify this
afternoon
um thank you I have um only four copies
of my testimony I ran out of printer
paper okay so I don't know how you would
like to distribute them I also emailed
it to the chair the vice chair and the
secretary um my testimony is mostly
pictures
okay you can give a copy to the clerk
and we we'll be all good is
this my name is Bonnie Christie I'm from
hopkington
and I really appreciate that the
committee is holding the hearings on epr
today um I support HB uh 1630 and I urge
you to vote out to pass on it I'm
speaking for municipalities and I'm
speaking for taxpayers when I support
this
bill this bill outlines the Keystone to
addressing New Hampshire's waste crisis
which is reduction of the waste before
it becomes waste combined with Shifting
the burden from the consumer and the
towns to those who produce the waste in
the first place enactment of this law
would provide a huge benefit for the
towns of Hopkinson and Webster who share
a transfer station which is located in
Hopkin
Hopkinton um most of what I'm sharing
today comes from my experience as the
chair of the waste reduction committee
um and as an environmental polic analyst
I'm no longer chair of the committee and
I am not speaking for the committee or
the town I'm speaking as an individual
today but that's where I get my
information
from the most important thing you can
take away from my testimony today is
that our town and I'm sure we're not
different from other towns is drowning
in waste drowning in
waste it's both the the waste that gets
thrown into the hopper you know the
compact that pushes it into the trailer
that takes it to the
landfill and it's also the recycling
streams that we send to Market to
produce offsetting revenue for that
waste we have to pay for in tipping fees
at the
landfill The Lion Share of this waste
could be avoided by Source reduction in
this case the reduction of packaging
that you've heard before the EPA
estimates that about a third of our mssw
which is our Municipal Solid Waste comes
from
packaging and that is why New Hampshire
has set Source reduction of waste
materials at the top of the hierarchy
for preferred Waste Management
strategies I think Christine just
mentioned
that well as they say p a picture is
worth a thousand words so I've provided
you a few visuals of what I mean when I
say we're drowning and
waste um Hopkinson and Webster are are
Source separating recycling towns which
means that instead of putting all of our
recyclables into one bin we separate
them out into
streams we have cardboard paper aluminum
steel cans plastic bottles and jugs and
the first picture in my statement which
I'll try to show you is our cardboard
this was on
Saturday I don't know if you can see
that in the middle is the cardboard Bay
it's spilling out all over the parking
and drop off area
to the left of the cardboard is our
mixed paper which you can't even see
because it's so full and so full of
overflowing cardboard and to the right
is our bailing station that's where we
have our Bailer to bail it up and send
it um bailed materials always command a
much higher price in revenues on the
recycling Market than loose materials
which is why we bail them
up um so you might ask you know is this
mess of cardboard and packaging is just
just a glut of materials from the
holiday season well I could show you a
similar picture taken on October 14th
that doesn't look much different yes
there's always more waste after the
holidays but we are always drowning in
it so we we just can't keep up with what
comes into our towns
and what happens to this cardboard that
you see spilling out all over the place
when we get 8 Ines of snow like we
did it's it's destroyed you cannot
recycle and send to Market wet cardboard
so cardboard which we get about $100 a
ton in revenue from once it gets wet
because we don't we have so much we
can't store it we can't keep up with
bailing it it goes to the landfill so in
the landfill at TurnKey we pay
close to $100 a ton in tipping fee so
what should be a revenue of $100 a ton
to offset our cost becomes a cost to
throw it in the landfill it's an expense
to the
town so cardboard is
packaging you can see how hard it is to
keep up with this steady
inflow um and cardboard is just one of
the recyclables that we take in you move
move down in um my statement you see
aluminum
cans mostly you know beverage
cans
and aluminum the price has gone up and
down and uh we have a real backlog of
aluminum now what we get bailed up we
are now storing in shipping containers
sitting at the transfer
station
and then we move on to
plastic this is number one pet p called
Pete it's basically your
bottles um Pete has been Rock Bottom in
the market lately it's very hard to move
Pete it does go up and down but it's
been down for a long time I mean that is
just a flood so what do we do with all
that then we have our number two to
natural
jugs you can
see basically milk jugs anything that's
not colored plastic that commands the
highest price in Plastics and the reason
is because when they reuse it and
recycle it it can be dyed to any other
color but once you get a dyed color you
can only make it into that dyed color
again so this is the Overflow that we
have in that what I'm getting at is it's
just really hard to move these
recyclables it's not that people aren't
bringing them in and recycling them it's
hard to move them in the
market so all of this packaging it only
represents what people choose to recycle
what doesn't get recycled goes into what
we call the hopper which is the
compactor that pushes it all into the
trailer to go to the
landfill and as I mentioned before that
tends to be about a third
of our
MSW
so we generally produce about 3,200 tons
of MSW a year in hopkington and Webster
so a third of that about a th000 tons
is it's just
packaging and it costs taxpayers over
$100,000 just to dispose of that
packaging so what causes this overflow
in this glut of all this stuff well
there are a lot of factors but for
practical on the ground purposes you
might ask well why can't we just bail up
faster and move it faster to the market
I already mentioned that the markets are
up and down and a lot of them are very
slow but then we have a staffing problem
at our transfer
station it's not a glamorous job to work
at a transfer station and the least
glamorous of the unglamorous jobs is
bailing recyclables in the Bor building
these these are uh part-time workers
they receive no benefits the work is
hard it's dirty and it's physically
demanding it's very hard to keep we have
three positions for part-time for this
it's very hard to keep it staffed up and
then we look at the infrastructure what
does it take to bail up all this stuff
and move it all this packaging that we
wish we didn't have well Hopkinson has
an older style Bor it's a vertical Bor
what we really need is a horizontal
bailor a vertical Bor takes about three
staff people 5 hours to produce a bail
if you have a horizontal Bailer it would
only take two staff people an hour to
produce a bail so why don't we just get
a horizontal Bailer well horizontal
bailers cost
$90,000 it's a lot of money that's not
the only infrastructure need in capital
Improvement need that we need at the
transfer station we have to keep up with
our trailers we have our our loaders and
we have all the other equipment that we
need to process
waste so that's that's just a lot of
money our um waste uh transfer station
budget this year is the highest it's
ever been
$800,000 that's
astronomical and on top of that
hopkington has a pasas problem our
septage lagoons which had to be shut
down by
Dees were receiving all kinds of toxins
and
pasas so they had to be shut down and
now we're facing a 4 million bond to
clean that pasas up and that doesn't
even include the pasas that's in our
wastewater treatment plant sludge that's
a whole separate thing $4 million last
year we passed a 2 million doll Highway
Bond at town meeting everybody was like
o that's a lot but we realized it was
deferred maintenance wait till people
see the $4 million Bond warrant article
at town meeting people are going to say
what the
heck anyway what I'm just saying is that
waste is very very expensive and of
course the operating budget and the
capital Improvement fund all comes from
the taxpayer that's us that's the little
person so that's pretty much my
testimony I hope that the pictures help
give a visual of where we're at I did
want to mention that um my very last
point is director whimet um was talking
about not being able to support this
bill because of needing eight staff
people I can totally appreciate that
would take a lot of staff to implement
an epr program however governor sununu's
Administration just recently in uh fall
of 2022 issued a solid waste management
plan it has eight goals and each goal
has strategies and goal number one is
guess what source reduction because the
cheapest waste for taxpayers to pay for
is the waste that never gets produced in
the first
place so if you go to Pages nine and 10
and that you know when the question was
asked in the the solid waste working
group did they ever work on epr well not
directly on this bill but that was a big
part that plan came out of the solid
waste working group and that was a big
part of what they talked about and it
ended up being goal number
one as I mentioned there are strategies
in all of these goals and there's a
legislative strategy for each one and
for Source reduction it says explore
legislation including extended produc or
responsibility programs that would
require product Brands and manufacturers
M manufacturers to enhance the
recyclability of their products and
packaging and minimize the use of
unnecessary materials and single use
Plastics this is the sonunu
administration's plan it's right there
in black and
white so hb1 1630 does exactly that it
starts that
process so in conclusion um waste
management is a huge burden for towns
and for taxpayers for operating budgets
and our Capital budgets and we
desperately need help to reduce these
costs they're so
unnecessary so we urge you I urge you to
vote ought to pass on this bill and I
appreciate very much that you heard my
testimony and I know it's been a long
day so thank you so much thank you any
questions in the committee
representative dsy uh yes C uh what is
the population of
Hopkinson approximately hopkington is
just over 6,000 and then we share
transfer station with Webster so I think
the combined um residential contribution
is a little over 700,000
people sorry yeah we're not that big yet
7,000 sorry yes yep
so thank you so I just just a comment
maybe question I don't
know it seems as if as if your recycling
efforts in hopkington have been more
successful than what hopkington can
handle I mean people are bringing in
recyclable items cardboard
plastic and various other you know class
ifications of
plastic um and I realized that
municipalities do have a an expense in
handling that material and being able to
handle it in a way that would bring them
top dollar for uh being able to dispose
of it through um secondary
handling
so if we're I guess I know this bill
seeks to reduce uh the production of
packaging but there's also so much
packaging that we really can't get away
from and if we are say um foregoing a
lot of plastic to use cardboard
instead then I would imagine that our
municipalities would want to be able to
accommodate that
um uptick in in uh the use of other
materials which are more
preferential so how would you say um how
would you say
that recycling efforts are they not are
they not working properly for these
towns um I can say that well I can give
you another factoid which is that every
year we calculate what percentage of our
total waste is recycled and every year
it's been going down and down and down
we're now down to 133% the highest we
ever were was
22% meanwhile the waste going to the
landfill the tonnage has been going up
and up and up over the last decade our
tonnage increased over 20% that were
sending to
TurnKey and our population increased
less than 6%
so there's there's more stuff going on I
think in terms of your question about
the packaging and will this just bring
more that maybe we'll have struggle
continue to struggle to handle I think
the goal is to minimize packaging there
will always be a need for a packaging
the question is what kind of packaging
what can you do with it at the end of
its life
cycle and you know why do we need you
know you see people put going to the
grocery store and putting one or two
items in a big shopping bag why you you
see vegetables I like to go to hanford's
and you know they have what I call the
naked produce section you know there's
no packaging I love that but in other
places you will see you know a head of
broccoli wrapped in plastic why you know
let's minimize and get rid of all the
unnecessary packaging and let's use the
packaging that we really need for you
know protection of the consumer goods
and for health and safety and to make it
manageable and profitable for the
grocery stores and restaurants and so
forth that that handle things but you
know when when I pick up a pizza at my
local place and they automatically throw
in a
plastic wrapped um bundle of plastic
utensils knife Fork and Spoon
and I I've got a pizza and I'm like why
it's it's just we have this this sort of
um autopilot thing that has been going
on for a long time people figure oh it's
take out you need some
utensils it's not that hard to rethink
that and I think it really does come
down to minimizing using only what's
necessary and using the best materials
possible thank
you represent
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question um I'm curious to
know if I um understood you correctly in
saying that um you made mention to I
think I'm going to reference your photos
so thank you for providing those um this
shipping container that sits now on your
property because um if I heard your
statement correctly the markets are not
necessarily supporting you getting it
off your site fast enough is that what I
was hearing that's part of the problem
is you it it's not economically
efficient to send out small loads you
wait until you have I don't know what
they call them a full a full load and so
you always have some Bales sitting on
the premises but the other thing is you
know those baales are not going to move
full load or not if the cost is gone
like this so that's why they sit there
um follow if I may sure follow up uh
thank you madam chair and I mean no pun
intended but are you concerned that
municipalities are going to be left
holding the bag on like having a bunch
of material sitting somewhere that
because I'm really I'm really worried
about that I mean the other reason that
we have our cans in in shipping
containers is because our recycling shed
where we usually store these bailed up
things waiting for Market
is I mean it's got holes in it it's got
leaks in the roof I mean there is so
much deferred maintenance and it would
cost so much to bring everything up to
spec in our transfer station it's just
people have no idea what it costs to
manage waste
so I mean that's that's part of it but
yes I think we are now holding left
holding the bag on this kind of stuff
and I'm very concerned about Plastics
because now there's this movement as
somebody asked is consumers are asking
for um you know different kind of
things and more recyclable things and
more eco-friendly things for packaging
so you know for example the the number
one pet like your soda bottles there's a
lot of things now and you look on the
label it says made with 60% you know
recycled plastic okay recycled plastic
is not as good as virgin plastic I mean
it works the first time around but every
time you mix that in with the Virgin
plastic then you've got this degraded
plastic and as I think Christine
mentioned I forget what the fact is
about how much plastic the Plastic
industry is you know planned to produce
the increase in the next decade it's
astronomical and the they're saying oh
just recycle it all it's not going to
work I mean I think part of the problem
with the pet is there's a glut of
plastic out there you know there's a lot
of it and there's more and more so you
know it's a supply and demand thing the
cost the revenues go down when the
supply is just
flooded so y representative ger thank
you very much uh I wanted to I'm glad
representative Murray asked the question
she asked and I I was going to to say
that it looks hopk content it sounds
like it's about a quarter of the size of
Kean roughly and I know that one of the
problems that we have in Kean is for
example with number five plastic and
this has to do with this plastic that
you get stuck with so right you can
advertise if you're cuing you can
advertise that these K cups are
recyclable but this is also where we get
into the limitations of the market Keen
at four times the size of Hopkin can
Hopkinton can't gather enough number
five plastic to make it feasible to sell
that plastic so theoretically there's a
market but in reality there isn't a
market this is recyclable it ends up in
a landfill because of the limitations of
the market I can only imagine that that
must be even more true for a community
that's about a quarter the size of keen
that's that's exactly true I mean it's
yeah number five has been a problem for
a long time we actually did we never got
revenue from it but we were able to sell
it to a company called preserve which
makes things like toothbrushes and
you'll see things in the grocery store
made by preserve um out of that number
five
polypropylene
um the pro I don't know what happened
covid things fell apart with preserve
and covid and they never came back so we
have not had a vendor to to give our
number fives to even though we always
had to pay to get rid of it to preserve
it was cheaper than paying what it would
cost to landfill it so it was still a
good deal um
this is one of the problems with the
recycling Market it is so volatile it's
hard to plan um it's hard to know month
to month I mean there are times when we
couldn't get rid of cardboard or paper
and then people around town are like oh
I I heard we can't recycle cardboard
anymore you know four months later when
the cardboard Market has come back they
still think oh I can't recycle cardboard
anymore so they're throwing it in the
hopper it's just it's so hard thank you
very much
okay anyone
else no thank you very much for your
testimony
today and um my apologies to the
committee that uh the day has gone so
long but such that it is we've got a lot
of uh interesting things that we will be
discussing this is why we scheduled this
yes um okay so uh with that I guess uh I
will VI you oh yeah the blue sheet blue
sheet for uh hp1630 which I have here I
just have it right here and that's
something okay so the online testimony
we had
109 people sign in in favor of this bill
seven people signed in against this bill
and on the blue sheet we had three
people sign in against this bill and one
person in favor and I would say the
three people of the three people that
signed in against the bill was the
business and industry Association a
member of and a member of the wine
Institute so just so that we
know and with that I am going to close
the hearing on hb1
1630 and uh I B you all a good rest of
the evening and uh thank you all for
your time and your
attention
and